Magnus Carlsen has started his game he
has since Frolic 70 67. we have the
questions off we have liftoff that is
all that matters
ladies and gentlemen the pro chess
League Championship has begun there is
no more weight Anna I think we did a
pretty good job filling in there
coming up with things to talk about yeah
we did a good job and maybe now we
should look at the games yeah absolutely
so Nicholas Rosenthal he's he's been a
top GM Slayer for those of you who
haven't been following the pro Chesley
closely he's been he's had as good of a
performance rating as just about any
board four he beat Maxim Bashe lagrav uh
in in St Louis's match with uh with the
Marcel migraines and you know Maxine
blachio the groove in case you don't
know is about number five in the world
right so I mean that's a pretty good
upset obviously we don't expect him to
do the same to Magnus Carlson but he's a
very talented youngster and sees tactics
about as fast as anybody so this will be
an interesting one to watch
how do you like these kind of openings
the Italian the Italian I think uh I
think Mr Nicholas Rosenthal is is taking
one out of Magnus Carlson's book uh
playing a little bit of a flexible
opening here uh not playing any any
really forcing opening uh E4 games
nothing nothing too crazy with D4 right
away
um just gonna get a flexible position
it's a it's a Spanish it's either like
one of those uh I guess anti-berlin
spanishes or white plays D3 or an
Italian game it's a very flexible very
solid approach for white
let's check in on the next one here Ben
Feingold has also started his game
against
and I tried to figure out what tiar
compound means in Norwegian but Google
translator failed me so if there's
anyone no reason in the audience please
tell us what Tia compound means but I
could figure out is that compel is
complex that's all I know so he's maybe
it's like a combination of his first
name and the word and complex I don't
know maybe a very complex guy for sure a
very complex guy for sure to choose a
username like that but uh in this game
he is playing Ben Feingold with black of
course Grandmaster Lee is uh
he's over he's higher rated on our
server just barely I I don't know who I
would consider the favorite here I think
this is a huge game this is a huge game
this kind of matchup will tell us early
on who's going to take the driver's seat
in this match so let's see so we have
that game started we also have the game
against Grand Master
varicobian and of course video Master
yokim Nielsen
um this is also one of those games where
we're going to see very quickly can
Norway's underdogs can their FMS hold up
against the boards two and three of St
Louis GM's Jacobian and Feingold uh this
is this is every game is Big of course
but the angle here I think is really
important especially early Anna where we
kind of expect Magnus Carlson to take
care of business I guess
right and so you want you want to see
what's going to happen on these boards
two and three really
yeah it's a it's going to be interesting
as you mentioned since they have two
feeder Masters on both three and four
the Gnomes
um which means that their board 4 is
stronger than say you know it is word
four but weaker than the three of the
archbishops so yeah interesting strategy
yeah interesting for sure now the one
game that oh wait it has just started I
was just about to say that one game that
hasn't lifted off yet is the game
between Sebastian milov and Grandmaster
Wesley so but that is no more Wesley so
blitzing out of the gates his his uh
it's become his trademark right it
doesn't matter who he's playing he just
plays as long as he knows the move
there's no psychology there's no
psychological reasons for him to spend a
single second he just sure blitzes
blitzes things so quickly
yeah and let's remind everybody about
Wesley so has been playing basically
every week and he has been scoring
basically every game he has so far
scored 33 and a half Point uh out of 37
games how crazy is that against
Grandmasters like uh Fabiano caruano for
instance no and the percentage is even
better than when we listed in the
pregame if you're just joining us you
missed uh good and bad you missed some
good pregame analysis by me and Anna you
also had the luxury of missing a little
bit of a slow start so uh you're 15 or
30 minutes behind but you really haven't
missed much but as we talked about Anna
uh Magnus also has 27 out of 32 in the
games he's played so he's played about
five less total games scored a similar
percentage in those five games but
Wesley so has been uh Second To None as
you just said 33 and a half out of 37
games this is it's just mind-blowing
um all right well he's black here
against fide Master Sebastian mihiloff
uh I think that you know we've been
given all this all this cred to to board
four for St Louis right Nikki Rosen
Rosenthal
um but one of the things that as you
said May pay off is that this this is
board for feeding Master Sebastian here
is the board four for the Gnomes right
so you would think a feeding Master
should be favored
in the in it when when it comes time for
the boards for to take to take on each
other later on this match so we have to
keep an eye on that and see what happens
but okay let's see How likely is that
these two feeder Masters now uh one of
them is already an international Master
How likely is that they will score
against the grand Masters and How likely
is it that rosenthalvia score against
Grand Masters right right so it becomes
you know it's a combination of who how
will they do against each other and how
will the upsets go right
um
the uh
let's let's start analyzing some chess I
guess let's slow down and maybe try to
give the fans some something educational
beyond all of our our Heights can we do
that Danny of course we can and we can
we can do more than just the hype of
what this match means so what's going on
here Carlson playing aggressive is black
I I don't think it's very often that you
see black not only achieve the move D5
uh so easily in this Italian structure
but then also expand to D4
um
I mean some of the positional risks
there would have been if if Rosenthal
had sort of met that with a move like C4
this bishop on A7 is no longer as active
of a piece
uh but that that also comes with some
drawbacks because it gives black
probably a new Target to try to start
undermining and opening lines maybe a
move like B5 would follow what do you
think
yeah I agree that it's not an easy
decision to take whether you should
close the position or keep the tension
in the center so he clearly is
hesitating he pushed A3
um I'm not sure about that move
yeah it's a very strange flexible move
there by the by the young Underdog here
I think uh
either he's either he's
attempting to move this pawn and was
worried about access like a move like
Knight to B4 at some point right so he's
trying to Pro prophylactically guard the
knights entry
um or as you said a little bit of a high
class waiting move pointing out that
maybe Carlson doesn't really want to
take here because then white maintains
the solid Pawn group but Carlson's okay
with that he immediately played the move
Knight to D7
um which probably has a few flexible
ideas in mind maybe this Knight Finds
Its way over to the queen side to help
things and and maybe you also have
opened up you know the f-pawn if you
need to help solidify some defense over
here so I feel like black is equalized
pretty quickly shouldn't be a huge shock
here that Magnus Magnus got a decent
opening
um but but no real fireworks yet to
speak of yeah I like what he has
what is happening and he has managed to
make it interesting with this D5 D4 push
now it is really up to who is the better
chess player and I'm afraid that's
Magnus Carlsen probably is probably
we'll see right
um all right well let's take a look at
the the game that is moving along kind
of quickly with a lot of exchanges uh
Grand Master Ben Feingold and uh Grand
Master Lee let's so we had this we had a
queen scan but I think we had a regozen
no we had a queen C2 nimzo
uh but with with the D5 push we get we
get this structure that is very very
Queens Gambit decline not a traditional
nimso
um one of White's advantages in this
line everybody is that when the exchange
happens on C3 white will not be getting
the double pawns like you see in a nimso
but one of the disadvantages that white
has had to waste some time in order to
avoid that positional issue with the
queen and so black tries to kind of
expose the the moves that the queen
loses by opening the center early giving
you just a little bit of context in
terms of something that's very common
theory
um and that's what we have here is just
a position that has been reached many
times
um evaluation I think this is just about
equal white maybe has a tiny Edge in
this position theoretically but nothing
nothing super special to speak of yet
the big issue is we have to deal with
the C5 Pawn if we're black because right
now White's threatening to take it and
yeah what is aiming for is to reach a
position where Black's D5 Pawn is
isolated exactly so an end game would be
favoring him after C takes D4 or queen
takes D4
right or even Knight takes D4 but yeah
no I was uh anticipating what you were
saying yeah made those moves and I agree
with you I think this is White's goal is
to have a a small yet squeezable Edge as
they say right a a positional weakness
not not something huge to write home
about
um without tons of pieces but certainly
something white can press against for a
while
so the question for for Mr Lee is how do
you deal with that uh well
so he clearly doesn't want to have an
isolated Pole now after C4 uh the
question is always by the black can
support this bone quickly with B5 and
many times also A6 because now after B3
you have to react right here Here Comes
as you said Here Comes B3 I think I
think either you have to play B5 or just
take on B3 which normally the reason
this is a disadvantage everybody for
black white why you're not usually a
super fan of this is because
um in a perfect world yeah you'd like to
think oh white black has a three on two
but usually this overextended Center is
easy for white to undermine
um and so now if if black does have to
take here
this kind of position favors white this
isolated Pawn is still under Fire uh
black has a long term two on one but the
open lines on the queen side are kind of
giving white probably slightly better
middle game chances so I think that Lee
has misplayed the opening slightly I
don't I don't think that this is big
trouble but certainly some imprecision
imprecision has happened because after
B3 if you push B5 white can continue
with A4 and uh the same problem how do
you how do you protect all those pawns
right and and the main reason and I said
that everybody is because if A6 is
played we have a pin the pawn can
capture and this Pawn cannot move
without losing The Rook so this Pawn
chain is not as protectable as it seems
because of the lack of A6 uh as a
resource so it makes me feel like I'm
anticipating B3 he will take it and
that's that looks like what he did he
did take on B3 Queen takes so so I think
for sure we're headed toward a typical
fine gold game Ben likes these kind of
games a small positional Edge
um a comfortable squeeze
and he's and he's better positionally to
go with this isolated Pawn because this
bishop isn't the best piece on the
planet when the only Center Pawn is is
sort of blocking any any Mobility it
might have so I like I like Ben's
opening so far yeah I certainly agree
and also look at the time situation uh
he's got twice as much time uh-huh
so good chances for Banning this game
what about Jacobian yeah let's let's go
take a look at that
um and uh and see how how Mr Cobian is
faring here
interesting interesting game I uh
have a hard time guessing the opening of
how they got here off the top of my head
but I do remember it was in English
they'll move one C4 was played yeah yeah
well I wouldn't recognize the middle
game it has changed so much since
yeah so we had C4 E5
um and and a typical English with the E5
approach this bishop can either go to B4
or C5 in a lot of these positions
everybody this is very typical
um white plays for E3 and D4 and uh okay
this is this is all this is all kind of
standard I think white has a small Edge
in these positions basically because the
structure is symmetrical but white has
more space on on move 11 controlling and
restricting more squares there but but
it's not it's not a ton for black to be
worried about because there aren't
really a lot of positional weaknesses or
worries to write home about
um now a Cobian on move 13 and it takes
this interesting approach retreating the
knight from C6 back to B8 and into D7
what do you think is that just a sign
that he just didn't like the threat of
Knight to D5 coming yes he had to
prepare for 95 and I don't see a better
way to do that Bishop H7 and G5 looks
horrible so
I think he had to go for this knight
b897 move but I don't like his position
so this is not something normal that you
have to go back to B8 with the Knight
yeah it's not totally but again I guess
where I would focus on on blacks if he
was looking for some positive takeaways
as white has more space white has more
activity but there's yet to be proven
some sort of long-term concrete
Advantage right there's not really any
strategical weakness
um in Black setup he's just passive now
maybe he loses the bishop pair perhaps
this Knight chooses to capture on B6 or
something but I don't see any any real
long-term Dynamic issues for blackhead
it's just sort of a passive position
where he's a little bit worse which I
feel like is right where a Cobian wants
to be a position where he's a little bit
worse
the time I think so
I mean he plays the French for a living
right anybody who plays the French is
just used to being in bad positions
let's be honest I played a phrase I I
know but you got you get used to it
after a while right I know we like to
suffer you just you get used to
suffering and so you convince yourself
that a position that's slightly worse is
actually just equal
um anyway I'm I'm poking fun at French
players but um
well okay so Bishop E4 that's an
interesting move aggressive
um
a quick superficial calculation by me
says that it works tactically
I also couldn't refute it I was looking
for some kind of a tactical Motif but I
think Bishop E4 is a good move
forcing uh the trade of the D5 Knight
so the boys
sorry there's some strange stuff though
right there are opportunities for G5 for
white and queen of four in some
positions I'm looking at let's just make
some moves since we have the luxury
whenever you see the board go gray
everybody that means we're in analysis
mode so if you're wondering how and why
that happens that means if you ever see
the board with this shade of color it
means that Anna and I are analyzing a
position that was not actually played in
the game not yet anyway
um just a quick Pro tip for those maybe
viewing chess.com broadcast for the
first time after Knight takes Knight
takes in G5 is this position becoming a
mess
it's it's a strange set I mean I look at
like Bishop takes F3 Bishop takes Pawn
takes G5 Bishop takes white has the
bishop pair and and black is under a
little bit of a bind but maybe I'm
underestimating that after Bishop F3
Bishop three uh black would have Knight
H7 Anna taking advantage of a pinned
Pawn on G5 because it's up here yeah
this is complex maybe maybe T5 is too
aggressive I see that the the guys in
the chat are very excited about Wesley's
position and some of you guys are
suggesting that he is lost uh I don't
think he's lost but maybe we should have
a look at it if it's uh not clear who is
better
I have just I have just turned there now
and I'm interested to see that first of
all I don't agree that he's lost at all
I mean yeah I love his position actually
yeah I mean he's got a positional
advantage in the end game where
um where white has some some weak pawns
yes he does have the bishop here meaning
uh feeding Master Sebastian mihiloff and
and he does have an active looking Rook
but
um the long term see when you balance
when you're calculating or evaluating a
position you have to look at both the
activity of the pieces but also the
targets and who actually has something
concrete to play for white has one
isolated Pawn three isolated pawns four
isolated pawns black has no isolated
pawns perhaps the weakest potential Pawn
is the A5 Pawn but it's very difficult
to see white winning this end game if
anything I think black is the only one
with chances to win so sorry to burst of
bubble there would you agree Anna I
definitely agree I love and I have
healthy Pawn structure and my opponent
has these horrible poems but I think
maybe some of you guys were worried
about Wesley's position because White's
Rook is very active and also the Bishops
but as Danny mentioned that is something
uh that either you have you can use it
right now some Dynamic factors or on the
long run Black's position is much better
because of the pawn structure so his
only problem is the passive Rook so once
he can exchange groups or activate his
Rook he should be fine yep it'll be
interesting to see I mean yeah it is a
little bit tricky to activate this Rook
when you're worried about what that
other Rook might be up to but I have a
hard time believing there won't be a way
to balance defense there and maybe
create some open weaknesses here in fact
maybe even look for Wesley to consider
some way to try to let white trade off
one of these weaknesses but maybe open
up the king side a little bit to create
some other avenues for The Rook I don't
know just uh just throwing it out there
as a okay I like this move as well I
think that trading off the Bishops
Highlights Highlights the night
advantage over the light score Bishop
even more because it gives this Knight
access to squares it didn't have access
to the bishop on on the light squares
may end up becoming one of those
innocent bystanders where he's sort of a
purposeless purposeless piece to prevent
the knight from maneuvering around on
the dark Square so that's that's enough
exactly exactly the F4 Square for the
night that's a beautiful Outpost so I
like that Sebastian when Bishop E1
trying to keep the bishop but it also
means then now his Bishop is very
passive on E1 and the F4 Bishop is fine
um I don't know what's happening in the
chat but you guys like to say that
somebody's losing nicely Magnus costume
losing I'm not sure that it's true but
we have to check it they just like that
you're paying attention to them they
like that you're following what they're
saying in chat and and so if I if they
have to say something to get your
attention maybe that's what they're
doing
um so now they're claiming Magnus
Carlson has lost also yes not really
something I agree with this is a little
bit more tricky this is a dynamic Affair
where okay Rose and salsa has landed
himself a light Square Bishop that the
world champion lacks however the D3 Pawn
is weak I'm considering moves like
Knight to C5 which have a double attack
on both D3 and B3
um Shirley Magnus will be calculating
here but the biggest issue for Nikki
really if you're evaluating the
Practical factors which you always have
to do everybody is the time right Magnus
has about a five point Sorry a five
minute time Advantage which will be
significant if it stays that way and
things keep ticking away
yeah I like Knight C5 I think that's a
great idea and after Bishop takes C6 you
can simply attack this bishop and
threaten Knight B3
so yeah I like this movement I guess
that's what he's calculating
probably trying to calculate more than
he even needs to one of those things
where maybe he knows
um
maybe he knows that Knight C5 is the
move he wants but he's he's got to
calculate oh wow look at that he had to
calculate I guess I was just looking at
he had to calculate Bishop takes C6 with
the tempo on The Rook followed by maybe
the maybe the bishop was able to get
back with Tempo and suddenly E4 yeah
maybe that was the key and of course H3
is hanging it's a little bit complex but
it looks like perhaps Magnus didn't like
the risk of that decided to play C5
which is just a surprising move because
that square was built for a pony not a
pawn exactly that's not a fun move to
play
yeah I'm a bit surprised but
um I I also think that he understands
the position somewhat better than us so
maybe he's right I mean he's Magnus but
you know I don't know I mean we'll give
him a pass on that sure look at that
Knight F6 and he could go Knight H7
Knight G5 maybe okay I don't think he
will get there but that would be lovely
to play Knight G5 right if he can bring
the Knight to G5 everybody what happens
is an attack on H3 there uh the big
issue though for for black is he has to
figure out what he wants to do as soon
as this light Square Bishop puts itself
on e4 yeah
Rosenthal is going to ask him what he
wants to do right now
probably a trade and again followed by
execution on the B file if I had to
guess magnus's move I I really like Rook
to B3 yes
at one point which speaking on guess the
move points of course we should remind
everybody that if you're in chess.com
following the games not just on Twitch
or chess.com TV uh following any of the
games you get to guess the move yourself
and try to play like the top players of
course after every game it rewards the
top guessers sometimes we get super
strong Grand Masters playing Guess the
move and it's actually a lot of fun to
see uh guys in there trying to guess
what their peers are playing so I really
like Carlson's chances here the B file
is
the B file is booming and business is
good so I I think Magnus is going to
take this one let's see what's going on
in feingold's game
wow tripled on the C5 but is that enough
it's it's definitely enough to to say
what we what we said earlier to be true
which is that after B3 white would be
the one who had access over these open
files and so sort of have a better
middle game right Anna but but is it
going to be enough long term because if
one of the things to keep your eye on
everybody is if if the position
simplifies out the more pieces come off
the board two things happen one the D5
Pawn becomes less and less of a
targetable you know offender you can't
really attack it if you don't have
pieces to attack it and number two
blacks two on one becomes more and more
of a reality so black is a little bit
worse in these middle games because of
this opening we talked about but if this
simplifies out look for lead and maybe
have a better chance in the end game
than we then than he had in the middle
game right
yes I think so I think that he has
managed to to somehow protect everything
and after B6 if you force the exchange
of Rooks on the C file that that is
still a slightly worse position but
probably holdable for black anybody he
probably has to take with the bishop
first right because if you take with the
Rook I think I think
yeah so I think if I think after Rook
takes we're going to see Mr Waite I'm
wrong he took with the Rook
what what is
he wants to play Rook A8 after Bishop
takes A6 ah interesting interesting uh
and that works it works because white is
unable to defend the bishop and the A3
Pawn at the same time yes
that might have been a miscalculation
right there by Ben I think Ben took C8
quickly anticipating that that that's
exactly what would happen meaning the
move I suggested Bishop takes C8
sometimes someone plays Rook takes and
you're like oh wait that that was what
they were calculating but okay he's
going for it yes still he run for it so
what does he want to do here I I think
the tables are turning a little bit I
feel like Lee is getting toward an end
game that black might be pushing a
little bit in because he's going to be
left with the only pass Pawn on the
board
yeah I'm a bit worried for Ben here
yeah maybe this is still okay but um
definitely not the correct trend
very good defense there uh what do we
see now whoa the Jacobian game
has gotten nutty as well Cobian Nielsen
um
I I black found a way to unwind the pin
there but
but in the process he's he's white has
increased the space advantage on the
queen side so B7 is immediately Under
Fire of course there's exchangers we
have to be looking at over here I think
on the in the immediate level a real
quick tactic I have to show everybody
for fun is that if a phobia plays a
simple move like Rook to B8 if you want
to pause this live show you have about
three seconds before I show you the
tactic white has this move Rook takes E4
coming smashing through on the diagonal
followed by Queen takes F7 and Knight G6
check Alina Les schlamba
um it's uh it's it's these kind of
double attacks after moves like Queen to
B3 Anna to get the fans on the edge of
their seat because there's even though
they even if they don't want to admit it
they're always rooting for a train wreck
so they're hoping somebody plays a move
like Rook to B8 it allows this allows
this train wreck sacrifice yeah there
are multiple ways to to actually blunder
it you can also go Queen C8 and it still
works so B6 is also bad
many bad moves here
yeah I I think um
I think vorah has his work cut out for
him what do you think he's going to play
He Is the time is ticking they're
getting closer to evil to equal what do
you think he's gonna play it's not easy
even if even if you spot the threat what
do you do against Rook takes E4 and
queen takes B7 at the same time how can
you prevent that
I
I was hoping you would tell me
I don't know
maybe if you could just protect Evan
Paul give up the B7 pawn and then you go
Rook V8 and Rook takes B2 because
White's King is also vulnerable okay he
one Knight takes G3
so he just wants to take all of them we
follow that with another exchange right
yeah the only way he's doing that is
because he now will play Bishop takes E5
indeed
so um
that that pressure that we talked about
has has been liquidated by black
um but who's getting the better of this
at the end black has the past D Pawn
but white has this open f file
um oh and now he's now he's really
showing that he calculated well Queen
takes B7 would be a poison pulling
everybody due to Rook B8 and suddenly
Black's pieces are jumping to life here
so
I like Black's position a lot I think
this is really really nice that he
calculated that after the trade of minor
pieces now White's post structure is
very weak next move can be Queen E7
double attack and also rookie eight
I I completely agree with you I love I
love uh Black's decision there to
simplify
the the smoke in the center and and
suddenly we see that
um the middle game had really gone awry
for white after that very very technical
combination one of the things that
Cobian does very well I I joked about it
people thought I was poking fun of him
but I'm I'm not kidding he's very good
at being in positions with a slightly
worse Advantage maybe a slight space a
slight space disadvantage and and
calculating the accurate and Technical
way out of it a Cobian is a very very
solid player and this kind of
simplification from a from maybe a
slight what was maybe a slightly worse
position before is something he does
very well he's done it against yours
truly more times than I'd like to
remember and uh and uh played played VAR
very very many times when I was actually
a real chess player back when I was a
real boy
um
informing us that Ben is about to lose a
piece minus Crossing is about to win his
game and also Wesley so is is already in
the final stage so where shall we go
okay I just checked on on the Ben
Feingold game because I think you could
argue that Ben Feingold losing this game
would be the biggest suggestion of you
know a first huge loss if Feingold loses
as white against one of the fellow GM's
it really makes life difficult for the
Bishops let's take a look at Wesley so's
game
he has one already look at those
postpones on e22. well I I I just saw
the final position of Wesley so winning
uh the point everybody a brilliant
brilliant recognition that the king is
in a mating net so this Knight is not
relevant uh White is simply checkmated
so Wesley so wins right at the exact
same time that Magnus Carlson wins those
pawns are nobody's friend uh those are
those are uh
those pawns are looking for a job
promotion and they just got promoted and
they they have taken the point for
Magnus Carlson so so both both of the
best players in the world as expected
they they strike
they strike as they should so Magnus
Carlson and Wesley so have one Anna now
we are focused on the other two games uh
Ben Feingold is losing a piece but he's
won I was saying that here this is
trouble but he has well Knight f8
checking G8 I was thinking that maybe he
has something there but I don't see
anything
so so what is this
um
uh sorry I'm uh
informing my team I don't know I mean
but is he the question is whether he's
getting enough pawns whether he's
getting enough pawns to compensate for
the Lost piece
D5
he's gonna make a mess of it as best he
can and it's not so simple I mean notice
should be there's weird threats with
Knight f8 check coming
yeah the Knight of Faith King G8 and the
King walks out with king after that I
agree with you I'm not not claiming a
meeting right away but I think Ben plays
E4 here to defend the pawn and the point
is yes okay we have an extra piece if
we're black okay he plays check first
But Here Comes E4 as soon as the as soon
as the checks are done I think white
plays E4 and then tries to just
focus on on making things complicated
you'd think with a computer playing
black with best play probably this is a
um this is a win for black although why
is he repeating maybe to just gain time
on the clock yeah look at that black was
about to repeat most he went back to H7
with the King and then decided that Rook
D7 was much better instead of Knight f8
yeah I like that you know Ben is up Ben
is up a lot of time and one thing that
Ben is really good at is is practical
decision making putting pressure on on
somebody and and he's trying to make it
make it hard for black to get that King
out of a mating net even though he's
down a piece
yeah so he will have two pawns for the
piece
um and also also this Knight only six
and The Rook is so active I wouldn't be
surprised if he had at least a draw here
after Knight F5 for instance
on Knight H5 yep that's better Knight F5
I like what I like what Ben is doing and
I don't know if he finds a way to
to convert or not but I but looking at
12 seconds for his opponent yeah he can
win back the night right now with Rook
d8 but the B Pawn is very Advanced so he
should probably go for the draw
F7 that's amazing net
okay
the main thing now is that he might mate
even if he even if he's
hmm
even if yes for d69 C6
losing on the board I mean play F4 and
this yeah
at least because he has he has Knight H7
check and no matter where the King goes
he can just rinse and repeat so Ben has
already established that that he's got
at least a draw here he's going to play
tickle and and try to put his opponent
in an awkward position but maybe now at
some point here he settles on the
perpetual
worried about them no he doesn't want to
he's not settling on the perpetual
no he's in a fighter mode he doesn't
want to draw at all but he may regret
that decision because honestly having
gotten as much practical chances as you
can ask for bringing down a piece if he
gets if he gets away from having that
guaranteed draw because now this King
can run out yes
you know his his time Advantage is also
slipping away uh quickly I know we're
focused on this excitement here I just
want to confirm that what I'm hearing is
true yeah it looks like a Cobian is
squeezing the fide Master yokim Nilsson
because these two pawns look to be a
huge Advantage Plus he's he's up more
than a minute on the clock so I expected
Cobian to win this let's oh wait Z4 what
wait is that's a that is a huge
combination that Jacobian may have
missed it first if Queen takes Queen
takes F7 and then Queen takes E6
black lacks any way to take advantage of
the king because the queen guards this
Pawn
that that might have been a huge
so where was the blunder then by uh he
he had to push the pump but then the C4
Pawn was hanging so this wasn't as easy
as it seems it wasn't as easy as it
seems and if Rook to d8 if this proves a
a turnaround of this position then that
will be that will be a huge turn of
events for Norway especially because it
looks like they were already on Pace to
take advantage
of the match if they can if if uh if Lee
can get a win here but maybe not maybe
maybe find gold finally settles on the
draw indeed he did just as we say that
um let's give some shout outs to our top
guessers playing Guess the move Marshall
10-8-2-2 that must be a zip code got 10
out of 21. feed a master johannesh gets
8 out of 12. a whole bunch of people
guessing Geppetto I see you there homie
number 10 with 5 out of 14. so lots of
people jumping in on guess the move
action in this fine gold game and now
we're focused on a cobians game with
Nielsen yes so
ready in Ben's game he finally went for
the Perpetual check
and that leaves us with jacobians game
which which we thought that was an
advantage for a Gobi agopian until Rook
takes D4 a huge blunder
yes suddenly suddenly
things are not so clear here I still
think that with White's King being as
open as it is it's hard to imagine black
losing this game a combination of the
outside B Pawn and maybe some sort of
some sort of Tricks against the king no
he invites The Rook ending what does he
see about this work ending that he likes
I guess he feels he could hold on to the
B Pawn and and be comfortable so
what he wants
slightly strange decision here uh
I feel like maybe Nielsen should have
traded Queens when he had the chance I
see that just from a practical
perspective with seven seconds balancing
a past pawn and an opening
exactly this is going to be too late
it's gonna be way too late here here
comes the win it just gets a queen here
and so I I think that that was a
terrible
terrible decision to to not not get the
Queens off the board when he could have
and he doesn't even have a second check
so that's it over that's it and that
means that we see the Bishops grab the
lead after the first round just like
that
things are now clear a Cobian wins
um the Bishops jump out to a two and a
half to one and a half lead and we have
a match here amazing stuff Anna your
thoughts oh
I don't know where to begin all these
games that we were following on board
two and three I mean of course we
expected Wesley so and I was crossing to
win easily that first game but in the
other two games it could have been
anything
wolf
yeah absolutely the the the so Carlson
and so take care of business but those
games in the middle as we said would be
the critical games this round
um they proved to be it seemed like
Nielsen started out well lost his
footing somewhere a Cobian did what I
kind of predicted he does best weasel
his way out of a worse position and then
uh yeah um the fine gold league game
that was the wildest game I I don't know
that either side can really be upset
with a draw and I'm sure both sides
thought oh maybe they could have won but
in the end that was a back and forth
Affair where
um it just it made sense that that game
would end in a draw
yeah this is exciting stuff and it has
only been one round three more rounds to
go and uh wow anything can happen we saw
yesterday that even if you start with a
point or two down it doesn't mean
anything
yeah both the Gnomes and the archbishops
were trailing behind for most of the
matches yesterday yep and
now we now we move into the slay the
dragon stage of the matches I like to
call it who will have a will anybody
prove uh their ability to maybe get a
draw a single draw a single scathing of
the armor of Wesley so or Magnus Carlson
could win the match for one of your
teams right if Feingold or a Cobian as
they take on the world champion can can
do anything to pull out a score there
that's going to be huge and and let's be
honest we don't expect anybody to slow
down the wrecking ball of Wesley so but
if somebody did if somebody did that
would be that would be um a huge huge
turn of events for there for their team
so we have about four minutes remaining
until the next match just so everyone is
aware don't go anywhere or maybe now
take that break go get yourself some
Cheetos
um or or some water
so in the next round we will see Ben
facing Magnus cross and if I'm correct
and Ben already yesterday said that the
Magnus is scared of him what are your
thoughts on that Danny
then Ben likes to say things and I and I
love that about him
um Ben Ben likes to talk and I know
you're thinking that's the pot calling
the kettle black but
um I love Ben Feingold love his humor
and Ben Ben the first thing Ben said in
chat yesterday after the Archbishop
squeaked by the chess bras in a in a
triple tie break around it was um well
that match was easy that was the first
thing Ben said in the in the chat so
um Ben's a trash talker we love it it
gets people excited
um maybe he's right maybe Magnus is
afraid of him but maybe it's not his
chest moves maybe it's his facial layer
I don't know
um who knows who knows why Magnus might
be afraid of Ben but if Ben's right
we'll see if that pays pays dividends
and and Magnus Magnus struggles against
the American
um so what's the other matchups we have
Feingold versus Carlson uh we have
Wesley so taking on Grand Master Lee
correct yes yes that is okay
foreign
facing me hi love fine gold Carson we
already announced and Rosenthal versus
Lee
yeah exactly so that'll be that'll be
what we see here of course the the if
you're just joining us everybody uh just
be aware that
um you've already missed a lot of really
really exciting stuff but uh but you
have not missed at all so don't worry
um we have round two getting set to
start here in in just a moment as uh
Anna said we will have so versus Nielsen
a Cobian versus mihalov Feingold versus
Carlson and Rosenthal versus Lee so this
will be it this is round two it's uh
it's getting set to get started the
games have not begun yet from what I can
see
yeah shout out to Greg shahadi of course
the Creator The Mastermind behind the
protest League we all love Greg and I
see one comment from Geppetto he's
saying that Greg shahadi whenever he
enters a room the collective IQ nearly
doubles
that's right I agree I 100 agree with
that also the collective deadlift
because Greg shahadi is a great CrossFit
uh Aficionado for those of you who don't
know Greg shahadi as somebody who does
CrossFit myself I look up to Greg Greg
lifts a lot of weight he uh
it's almost dangerous what Greg can do
in a gym so
um anyway no but seriously Greg Greg uh
an awesome job everybody involved in the
Pro chess League I think we should also
give credit where credit's due it's
unfortunate that so many uh teams are
not here yet but there were so many
teams that had had just phenomenal
Seasons I mean yesterday the chess bras
literally lost by a single hair on their
chin it was it was a one it was maybe
one move one moment many people
predicted them to be here in the finals
they they did fall to the St Louis
archbishops at the the Stockholm
snowballs were also very close
um so can't wait for next year I think
we'll have probably all the same teams
back maybe maybe a few uh mixed rounds
maybe I don't know what changes we're
gonna make next year but uh continue to
tweak things as best we can to make it
the most entertaining experience
possible so um I'm waiting I'm waiting
oh no longer need to wait here we go the
games have begun
Magnus Carlson going back to the London
he's played the London several times
although it didn't go well for him
against him on Hamilton when uh when the
Montreal uh chess bras faced the Norway
gnomes he ended up getting a draw in
that game
right wasn't that a London it was a
similar structure I think yes I think
against
look at look at Ben Feingold taking on
B1 punishing Magnus for a huge blunder
out of the opening look at that
that's a common that is a common trick
don't be scared
that is a common trick that Magnus
Carlson just fell for with this move C4
the whole point of everybody is after
Bishop takes B1 no matter what white is
about to lose the right to Castle
because if the move Rook takes had been
played
Bishop to B4 check Knight to D2 would
lose a piece after Knight to E4 white is
just completely lost that would mean
that the move King E2 is forced because
of that Carlson of course anticipates
that he's blundered he takes with the
queen and he will now meet Bishop to B4
check I'm guessing with King the E2
anyway uh and uh but it's incredible
that he fell for this trip
seriously that is like a it's it's it's
one of those traps that because you see
it so rarely it's not cemented deeply in
the pattern recognition of every of
every chess player's brain people wonder
like how can world champions like that
blunder well sometimes you get an odd
obscure tactic that you haven't seen a
million times and and it makes for that
that practical opportunity that you
might forget something that happens and
and Ben Feingold has jumped out to a
pretty good starting position against
the world champion maybe Ben was right
yeah he is living up to the expectation
so wow now we see Magnus Crossings King
on D1 and Ben Feingold can he pull out a
miracle Victory with the black pieces
against the world champion
but I I don't know if a victory would be
enough yet just from getting that small
Advantage because yeah I know it still
wants to be played but but Ben playing
the right thing here everybody as soon
as white has lost the right to Castle uh
opening the center is what you want to
do forget about being solid and being
happy with that got to be aggressive and
and so Feingold is doing just that
trying to open as many lines as he can
to get at this King this is going to be
an exciting one to follow
yeah I see right through the
uncommentating on this is that the mag
is inconsistent he is overrated too so
yeah you said that uh right sodium yeah
Magnus Carlsen definitely overrated you
got you're going you're on the right
path there buddy
um the uh
okay so so Magnus blunders but he's he's
gonna find a way to wiggle his way out I
expect King E2 okay not yet I was
thinking King E2 and get the Rook to D1
and try to Castle by hand
um but look at that he just immediately
returned the favor speaking of opening
blunders is he about to go win this Pawn
on cease this is this is a blunder Fest
between Magnus Carlsen and Ben Feingold
they are playing like uh
coffee shop guys go ahead and say it
they're playing like a couple of coffee
coffee shop blunderers
um Magnus blunders out of the opening
and then Feingold Returns the favor
playing a little bit too carelessly here
with this allowing this combination of
the skewer on the C file the whole point
everybody is that even if this bishop is
defended somehow just making a move the
Rook will come and it's only a matter of
time before white wins upon with check
and now honestly the script might have
been flipped faster than we thought
watch Magnus Carlsen win this game
before move 25 I'm gonna call it I mean
seriously this is nuts right now Magnus
is just up a pawn and has a phenomenal
start to the game laughs after marching
to D1 with his King I see Mike Klein uh
with some fake news in the chat he's
saying fine gold began selling
pre-orders last night of his DVD how I
made Carson's king walk to Devon and I
still didn't win that's right
exactly we got we got angry Magnus
quickly turns into Happy Magnus and a
single in a single uh series of moves
there that was hilarious
um
how I how I how I how I took advantage
of a blunder on move 5 by the world
champion and still lost before move 25.
um
but uh no I mean I think Ben has a good
sense of humor I'm sure he'll laugh
about that one afterwards so uh okay
well let's check on some of the other
games that one held our attention Grand
Master Wesley so is taking on Joachim
Nielsen here and
um it looks like their game started a
little bit later than the others because
they're really only on move two of a of
a Petrov so we won't we won't focus on
that too much as they play one of the
most boring games ever
uh
okay Vara kobian has taken on Sebastian
mihilaf I don't know
the opening looks like a benoni
um do you have any experience with
bologna I mean benoni nope the bologna
do you
uh let's just pretend we are experts
75 takes away a lot of space that's
right the pawn on D5 takes a lot of
space and black is gonna play on The
Queen side no I mean of course that is
true uh I usually only get a benoni when
I've completely screwed up my openings
so that that's when I get a benoni
um
but the the whole point everybody here
is is it's a white has a has a space
advantage on the king side in an Ideal
World you'll see white get things like
E4 and F4 and get the pieces behind this
big Center to try to organize something
aggressive here also look for the D6
Pawn to be a target for black uh black
is going to try to use the little bit of
a head start on the queen side to try to
try to maybe continue expansion over
here with a B Pawn also look for The
Rook to come to the e-file and sometimes
if black can get some minor pieces off
the board in the benoni uh you see open
lines and open space start to become
available where black and black can hold
his own so white has space and wants to
use it black wants to wait for the right
time to maybe trade some minor pieces
and try to play on the queen side did I
do a good job of sounding like I knew
what I was talking about in the benoni I
think it was perfect I would buy your
DVD there you go right Danny talks about
things he knows nothing about but
because of his Masters and Bs it flies
um
what about the other games because uh uh
Lee versus Rosenthal
is a game that we haven't talked about
much it's an English opening
it's quite a typical middle game
I jump to it right now uh real quick
funny comment to say Legend Harley says
that Danny sleeps with those Magnus
Fatheads not true I only sleep with the
mvl fathead okay not true I'm just
kidding so what's going on here this is
uh
a strange one
not sure what's going on here yet
yeah I think black is comfortable I like
his position so I think this is roughly
equal and um
I don't think that Rosenthal is having
big problems here
right I guess the question is is is
White gonna get play on the C file and
maybe ideas like A4 and B5 before black
can organize something perhaps with F4
um you know or one of the sides decides
they don't like the pawn structure as it
exists and tries to undermine it with a
move like D3
[Music]
um
I'm not sure I I kind of like white
maybe a little more than you do because
I feel like if the Rook comes to C1
I feel like I'm getting I'm getting a
head start faster than you are but maybe
maybe black is going to play F4 right
now and I'm just wrong I mean does F4
look like a move Rosenthal can play uh
could be he can also go for rook d8 and
play for E4 so I think this this
position is Pleasant for black
um on the other hand in Magnus Crossings
game uh yeah that looks like uh Mike is
saying that he will not even make it to
move 25 so poor Ben
well I think he will he's he's gotten to
move 23 and he's only down a pawn but
seriously I have never seen a more wild
and quick turn of events where you know
again if you're just joining us the
world champion plays the dubious C4 on
move five in a in a London which is a
common trick to the symmetrical London
so if you didn't know it now you know
Bishop takes on B1 a shot in the dark
you know why it's a shot in the dark
Anna because as as beginning chess
players we all learn you never give up a
developed piece for an undeveloped piece
right you don't you don't give up an
active piece for a lonely undeveloped
Pony but in this case you do because you
get this check and all of a sudden white
loses the right to Castle
unfortunately though everybody Feingold
kind of returned the favor by misplaying
the position uh we were praising him for
opening it up but a little bit more
aggressively than maybe he should have
um and Magnus sees the opportunity to to
to get a combination where suddenly he's
just winning upon with check himself and
uh the tables have been completely
turned Magnus Carlson is going to go on
to win this game against Grand Master
Ben feigled so crazy crazy stuff for
sure yeah and How likely is it that
Magnus plays this C4 so you are given
the opportunity to have a
position with
black and then you give back the favor
three moves later
oh
okay wow
um
King to D3 what's he doing is he always
meeting him he's got Rook D6 coming with
me
yeah now wait that's an owie that's a
big Ally my five-year-old would say
that's that's an alley uh that's an
alley and uh
okay well it's unfortunate we won't pick
on Ben anymore let's check on the other
games Wesley so taking on Joachim
Nielsen
um black doing okay here maybe he's
black has gotten some active pieces and
white has a hanging Pawn structure but
but somehow I feel like this is all part
of Wesley so's diabolical plan I don't
know I feel like it must be
I don't know maybe C4 is coming in and
then D5 and white actually uses those
hanging Pawn weaknesses for good
yeah and he barely spends time so he
definitely knows his position still
I think when he wins almost every time
so it's safe to say that he's going to
win this he really went out on a limb
with that prediction right there that
Wesley so will win so it's a fact it's
it's a it's it's a fact there so
um all right well what's going on in a
cobians game kobeian and Nielsen have
got
uh
the kind of benoni that black players
usually like one of the things I talked
about when I was describing both players
goals was white should be the one
getting space on the king side here
black has found a way to relocate and
and start to get some space
um
this is going to turn into quite the
mess now white has to worry about the
week E3 Pawn which is currently Under
Fire
but but the move that forehead
positional reasons everybody it sort of
put the cramps on F5 which permanently
leaves that Bishop with something to be
desired this is um
this is a Nutty position I like that
this is this is complicated stuff here
yes I like White's position it's not so
easy to develop Black's pieces also to
move away the E8 Knight when this D6
phone will always be hanging after F
takes G5
um not pleasant
I apologize to the fans
um to uh that we that we missed magnus's
game finishing we showed the position up
till E5 uh but uh then we we turned away
and made the decision to no longer make
fun of Ben but we shouldn't have because
E5 was just winning on the spot we
should have highlighted the point is you
either win a piece or if you want to
pause your video to see why Ben Feingold
resigned it was because there was a dual
threat behind E5 it also threatens the
move
Knight to D4 Checkmate that is so I was
wrong when I said move 25 but you got to
give me credit that it was moved like 16
when I predicted that this would be a
win in 25 moves for Carlson and made it
to move 26 before it's just an amazing I
mean seriously that was mind-blowing
right Ben Feingold catches the world
champion sleeping but Carlson completely
turns it around and and either mates uh
the 40 year old GM in the middle of the
board or he uh or he wins a piece and so
Ben simply resigned
um fantastic I apologize to the fans for
us not being on that board when Ben
resigned but any final thoughts on this
one that was just I think the wildest
game we've had so far in the match I see
Benny in the chat so I think that's all
that matters now you see what in the
chat Ben is in the chat and he's saying
that Magnus plays okay Magnus played
okay right no Ben we were just saying
that it's not every day you catch the
world champion blundering on move five
and uh and he he turns it on against you
in such a way so sorry about that buddy
you should have let him Checkmate you
though I mean come on man right where's
your where's your love for the
entertainment of the fans Ben play it
out to mate dude all right
what's going on in this uh this uh other
game Let's see we already checked on
Wesley so
okay let's let's take a look at this
board four game this is kind of heating
up
yeah and Ben was also saying just uh to
mention that C5 was not working out so
he thinks that was the mistake C5 in his
in his game there we love when Ben jumps
in the chat yeah I think well from a
principal perspective we understand why
Ben would want to play C5 we were just
talking about it needs to you need to
open the center as soon as you can when
someone loses the right to Castle but I
wonder if even Bishop to D6 is I wonder
if the bishop should just come back to
E7 avoid any of the of the shenanigans
that happened there the king isn't going
anywhere and then get castled and
support C5 so from my perspective I
wonder if if Bishop to E7 was already
better than Bishop D6 anyway but okay
let's move on to the games that are
still live
um and uh talk about I feel like
Grandmaster Lee is slowly out playing
the youngster here anna I'm starting to
like White's position more with the C
file uh with the a pawn being weak Am I
Wrong maybe I'm wrong I'm usually wrong
no I like Black's position as well and
lots of space and as you said now he he
is exchanging Rooks on the C5 his only
problem is the A6 backward Pawn so
um once he can do something about that
for instance if he could push A5 and
create a b Post pawn that would be great
um Bueller Bueller is G7 hanging
oh yes
what's going on did Black just blunder
with Rook to C7
it's not possible right he should have
something
I'm looking I'm also looking and I'm not
seeing uh is Ferris Bueller a movie that
you've seen uh in Europe is it's a okay
so as we as we prepare for the speeches
Championship roll together I'm going to
give you I'm going to give you some pop
culture you know homework if that's okay
so we got to watch this day off okay
obligatory preparation American pop
culture awkward awkward in these
references awkward 80s movies references
John Cusack quotes and bad accents are
like 90 of my game okay so all right you
need to catch up on that stuff but uh
Bishop takes E7 is just winning here I
mean Rook to C7 by the youngster was
just a blunder so yeah we are trying to
see if he saw something but it's just a
blunder as you said yeah I don't I don't
and I I think I mean not to I I tended
to like White's position more than you
did I guess I felt like black was a
little bit under the gun because I see
the B Pawn being harder to Target than
White's already active pressure but
either way you're certainly right that
black should have been able to do better
than just blunder the G7 Pawn yeah no he
was fine instead of Rook C7 any move
that gives the G7 phone alive and this
position is is okay for black yep well
too bad for Rosenthal we'll see if he
can defend something and hold on but we
don't expect the king to be able to find
shelter when he's lost his clothes in
such a way in fact Here Comes The Mating
net it's on like Donkey Kong so if if
indeed Norway goes up 2-0 anticipating
Grandmaster Lee to be Rosenthal that
means all they need is a draw in either
of these other two games Anna to even
the match
yeah yeah they they have turned the
tables they were one point behind and
now with this Victory by Lee they were
suddenly lead
two more rounds of course this doesn't
mean that the Gnomes have won the finals
already but uh this is serious stuff
here honestly if you and I don't get a
tie break I'm gonna feel a little I'm
gonna feel a little disappointed right
we didn't get to do the commentary
yesterday and they got they got more
chests than they bargained for I feel
like we should get a title three three
tie breaks so first the the chess bras
and uh the St Louis archbishops they
ended up in eight eight in the rapid
games and then in the blitz playoffs
they once again played eight eight how
crazy was that it just it was totally
crazy what's going on here in this game
with a Cobian yeah I'm rooting for the
tyrex I'm rooting projects mihilov just
played this interesting shot with Knight
to E5 and a Cobian went into a bit of a
think tank before deciding he could part
with the dark squared Bishop but that's
a risky it's a risky piece right
whenever you're whenever you've created
such holes and you and you lose the
natural protector of that square complex
it's not exactly a fee in keto right
Anna but it's kind of the same thing
here white has a whole bunch of
weaknesses to worry about and uh
this maybe this may be tricky for a Kobe
and all of a sudden
yes and uh we were pretending that we
know something about the benoni that the
only thing I know about the banon is
that when Black's dark Square Bishop
becomes alive then that's trouble for
white so you see this bishop on D4 it
could end up on E5 threatening mate on
H2 that's when suddenly black is doing
fine in the benoni
okay so there's there's a move that I
really want to be able to play here if
I'm white and that's 92 Anna because
that Forks the queen and Bishop so let's
look at that after Queen takes E5 I can
eliminate this super dangerous piece and
after the queen has to capture there's a
number of things going on here including
capturing C8 capturing F5 there's a
whole lot of action going on on the
e-file something tells me that a Cobian
is is gonna be okay here if he plays
Knight E2 and that's with my completely
superficial calculation of the fork and
capture the bishop here but I think
that's what he has to do because yes I
miss that you can take my Bishop right
now I was already excited about Bishop
E5 no I think you're right and that
that's exactly what we should highlight
because you know uh in addition to
providing commentary on what these
people are playing we're trying to see
if we can learn something from the games
and that this is exactly the kind of
thing white should be worried about but
but I think a Cobian if he finds the
right move is still in the driver's seat
and one of the risks in an attack like
this Anna where black has really kind of
gone Kamikaze on the king side is what
happens if all the pieces disappear
right who who's the one under the gun
right yeah so
you have to be careful whenever you
launch an attack that opens up the pawns
around your own King because if
everybody comes off you may find that
the e-file and these open squares are
are not something you can really
you can really do anything about so
we'll we'll
um will
white white find this move 92. oh look
at that we have new color Square
highlights
look at that I can highlight green and
blue and red I'm so excited
then it is covering the analysis mode on
chess.com it's when you when you make a
feature request and you don't know that
it's live it's like I feel like a kid in
the candy store as our site gets better
every day every week our site gets
better all right oh look at that E6
Jacobian wants more than a piece he
wants the whole thing so what's he
planning on Bishop E5
how's he stomping babies he's got to
give up the exchange
I guess that's what he wants
wow so he he wants this he postponed so
much that he would not mind to give up
an exchange for it
he must I mean he likes the E7 the E6
pass pawn and maybe the potential to to
open a Black's King we gotta I got a
comment there from DP Norman in the chat
who says yeah this was the round where
the Gnomes were supposed to score
um and and kind of get back into the
into the match because these are
favorable pairings for Norway but he
feels that in the long run we he still
likes the St Louis matchup so
interesting comment there good points
maybe yeah um but we'll see how big they
can score uh Magnus has already won as
everyone knows this game with Jacobian
and mihiloff is very unclear how is
Wesley so faring against Yoakam Nielsen
well this this is a still a
slow start for this opening in the
Petrov not as Joyce as it was before you
already said that his plan should be to
push C4 and start advancing the hanging
pawns so that's what he's doing C4 next
move could be D5 no not D5 yet because
I'm hanging my Rook on A1 so after C4
she probably wants to move the road but
I also don't like the queen on D1 no he
goes for D5 anyway
that's an exchange sack and it's gonna
get funky and maybe the kind of exchange
sack that allows White's pieces to come
to life I think the idea everybody is
after captures A1 this Knight lacks a
useful Square you can't go to E7 you
can't go here you can't go here right so
if this Pony is headed back to B8 I like
moves like 95 for Wesley so or look at
this battery does he go Bishop E5 and
all of a sudden all of a sudden white is
is bringing the heat to the king side
certainly so this is the round of the
exchange sacrifices uh and Nielsen is
not taking it it was too dangerous to
capture The Rook
yeah smart smart decision instead he
retreats to E7 where the bishop
maintains defense over the night
um but quite I'd love that approach by
so there recognizing that he can play
this he can he can advance these two
pawns yeah and uh and that and that this
Rook was really uncapturable a poisoned
red Rook
um and so what now if black doesn't want
to take this Rook
so 95 and Bishop E5 are the two moves
that are popping into my head here
Bishop E5 is a more aggressive way to
get rid of this bishop and and maybe
open up tactics against a vulnerable
Knight right
um but 95
95 May force you to part with one of the
Bishops anyway right because because
it's threatening to take G6 and and
maybe maybe you have to give up this
bishop here yes um somehow I feel like
Bishop E5 is the better move though
after 95 Bishop H7 what's the next
follow-up for white
I'm looking for tactics I don't know but
I don't I don't see any any sacks so I
that's it makes me feel like Bishop B5
okay well good that that is what Wesley
did I feel like this was the right this
was the right way to create more
dysfunction in Black setup
yeah probably there's nothing concrete
after Bishop takes Knight takes Bishop
H7 but that's such a pleasant position
you can play Queen F3 for instance
um and just simply asking black how does
he want to protect everything right
yeah no great Point Queen F3 just
attacks F7 maybe I then bring the other
Rook to E1 and and let my coordination
do the talking right uh hopefully that
leads to good tactics
so it looks like so it remains in the
driver's seat we'll say that uh so the
other games that are going to be proving
big oh oh no we missed we missed one
unfortunately though it not surprising
because if you remember where we left
this game of course it was it was after
this uh unfortunately yeah
terrible terrible blunder uh by by Rose
and salsa just blundering away the G7
Pawn
um so let's just see how Grandmaster Lee
took care of business
more pawns fell after this blunder Queen
to D7 allows a nice little combination
Bishop takes B5 and the queen is simply
overwhelmed cannot guard Everything at
Once the pawn is pinned and uh the hurt
the hurt was on so unfortunate we always
like to see the end of the game but the
truth is we didn't miss much fans that
we weren't covering this this this game
quickly became a matter of technique as
they say in Russia and uh and
Grandmaster Lee went on to win very
handily so so there you go
the game between a Cobia and me
and me horse after the exchange
sacrifice what happened were just a few
moves uh right but who is better here
I mean I don't know this is this is a
huge game though because if we're
expecting Wesley soda to do what he does
best which is win chess games against
yoga Wilson then then this game here is
going to decide whether whether um
Norway has gotten back into a tide match
or not black has to at least draw this
game in order for them to be in the
driver's seat
and tie up the match yeah I think the
whole idea behind this exchange
sacrifice in connection with the E6
postpone was that the C8 Bishop cannot
develop and if you can't develop that
Bishop then The Rook on V8 is also not
playing so that's a huge problem for
black that he cannot develop his Queen
side I would try to push B5 or do
something about it because those pieces
are dead
I agree 100 in fact I really I don't
even like F4 I feel like F4 was played
yeah but this this Pawn isn't going
anywhere black I mean I think black has
to find a way to recklessly get the
pieces back into the game and look at
look at a Cobian grinding it out
G3 but still this F4 move uh looks like
it gives up the E4 square and also opens
the b187 diagonal for the D3 Bishop I
don't like it at all agreed totally and
I love this move A5 Yeah by uh by
Jacobian recognizing that holding back
the counter play on this side of the
board continuing to remind everybody
that this bishop and Rook will not get
in the game
um this is this has been a very nice
game by by Vara Kobe and I I'm expecting
his exchange sacrifice to prove to prove
worthy here I I don't see black getting
out of this this is just so tough
yeah this is the typical Petrosian
sacrifice that he sacrifices and then
maybe 20 moves later he's winning the
game but it's because it's a positional
advantage that he's gaining absolutely
the the only the key Pawn to get rid of
if you could if you were black would be
this Pawn here right if you're black
it's a red Pawn if you're white it's a
green Pawn it's kind of the key Point
holding the whole thing together so if
you know if black can get away with
Knight to C7 and and look for look for
some sort of chances against the D5 Pawn
he may still have a chance but
um but there's so many threats against
the open King it's hard to see black
having the time to do that
I mean Here Comes Here Comes G3 can I
can I play G3 and just take advantage of
the pin yeah you can certainly do that
but I'm sure he also has other moves for
sure Knight E4 is also an option and
then yeah I want to play 94 but every
time I do the queen can take on D5 so
yeah
well no but you're right though I think
that's a key point because if white can
do it that's what white wants but black
is Black's position is still hanging by
a small thread because of that move not
being possible
interesting interesting stuff
um
okay so Wesley so has has reached
optimal so mode his pieces are
coordinating on the king side
uh he's about to rush the F4 F5 attack
and and with it I think black's position
becomes harder and harder to defend
okay he plays C6 that's a risky move
because the queen loses defense but
there's no I don't see any concrete
tactical way for that to be punished
um right away so that means C6 really
may be a key point
sorry I'm just checking the chat and the
um Christian credit are saying that Dan
is from Arizona the whole state is a
tanning salon I guess that's the color
difference between you and I because uh
yeah I see that I'm being called a new
Michael Michael Jackson the tanning
salon no it's not a tanning salon in
Arizona because we have to spend most of
our time inside so that we don't die
um but yeah I guess you do naturally get
a little more sun
um we uh we're over 6 000 viewers so
thank you everybody for being here if
you're if you need to be reminded this
is the pro chess League Championship the
only thing uh that's more important than
this is nothing nothing is more
important than this uh whoa we have a we
have Houston we have a peace sacrifice
um the
the move Knight to F you know what's
interesting is so I play I I said C6
didn't have a drawback because I didn't
see any sort of powerful Discovery but a
simple retreating discovery
whoa
has left black really under the gun to
deal with the the now loose queen and
the threat of the E7 Knight so yokim
decided his only option was to go to SAC
town but there's no way you can justify
this peace sacrifice this end game yeah
but he had no move you cannot move the
Knight and also you cannot go rookie nor
Rook C7 he was losing the piece after
Knight F3 that's that's amazing right if
even if the queen if there was D6 a
beautiful recognition and shows you the
difference between me and so I I saw no
power Discovery and gave up on the idea
of moving the Knight he plays the
awkward Knight F3 Retreat and black can
probably resign I mean this position is
just losing
and uh there's no way black will get
enough to justify this psac I mean
I'm not even calculating moves here but
I just don't we don't believe in the
power of the C Pawn maybe bishop C4 here
is okay
um okay he decides to take and and now
what
he's gonna just go gobble B7 and then if
C2 Rook C1 and I think he thinks he's
just gonna go slowly gather that pawn
it's not going anywhere yeah this this
is hopeless Knight F3 what a beautiful
move
yeah very very strong move Wesley so
continuing to play the kind of Chess
that others can only dream about
um
varicobian is is putting on the hurt
to feed a master Sebastian mihalov right
now uh St Louis is just proving to be
stronger because even if you know with
it with these two wins if a Kobe and so
win you could argue that even in a round
where where Norway maybe was a little
bit favored on the boards they couldn't
quite come up with a plus score and so
now now they're looking for upsets in
the later rounds or uh or this match is
headed a Direction Where where St Louis
will be crowned so
tough this is a really good example of
what happens when you don't develop your
pieces this specific Rook is all right I
had a chess coach who would just come he
would walk by all of us playing practice
games as kids and if he saw a game like
this where someone wasn't using their
pieces he would just take them off the
board and keep walking he was he was
kind of a jerk honestly
um but but he he was proving a point
that if he weren't going to develop the
pieces then he would just take them from
you
oh it's true those pieces the CH bishop
and the the B8 Rook are not doing
anything and it's all thanks to This
brilliant idea by Jacobian pushing E6
sacrificing an exchange for the sake of
crippling those two pieces on the queen
side
yeah let's go back up to when that
critical moment happened uh E6 was
played here the pawn became uh the
strongest piece on the board really in
many ways and uh these these pieces
would never be able to join the fight
um so it took a little while for white
to really prove that but as the pieces
get open lines on the king side this
king gets in more and more trouble and
uh eventually I mean I think we're about
to see a a win here for for a Cobian
over me Hill off it uh just doesn't look
like any other result is possible
okay and uh and so is is also slowly
taking care of business so
so we are going to have a 2-2 tie with
Magnus Carlson and Grandmaster Lee
having already won here we see Wesley so
wins Nielsen just resigns
um let's let's give some shout outs some
love to our guests the movers so many
guessing the move uh let's see we had I
I can't even keep up with it the chat is
going nuts but we had TJ e-chess with 13
out of 16 evl bone Z with 18 out of 26.
that's pretty good 18 out of 26 moves
so uh thanks for playing Guess the move
on chess.com let's see and make sure
Kobe and up yep right after Knight takes
D6
black through in the towel
um they'll let me know soon Anna how
many how many seconds we have until the
next round starts but let's bring up the
full scoreboard scoreboard uh maybe I
can still talk
um four and a half three and a half the
Bishops lead what have you learned about
the match so far and and any insights
you want to give the fans here
um I agree with David and Greg they have
just sat in the chat that Rosenthal will
be crucial in the next round so Norway
has a real chance if Rosenthal doesn't
score
um so round three and four are crucial
in this sense that's when Rosenthal is
facing the two feeder masters from
Norway uh can he draw or even win
against one of them that could really
give Saint Louis The Edge but if he
doesn't well
problems for the archbishops yeah that's
a that's a great point because I think
that we've been uh going off of D Point
DP Norman's comments in the chat who who
said he made the comment about the gnome
sort of being favored in that round so
if they couldn't score it's a bad sign
but the truth is you know Norway kind of
has a bottom heavy team this this
um this lineup right they've got two FM
so now Rosenthal he's got to take on two
technically stronger opponents and I I
picked into St Louis to win the whole
thing partly because I believe Rose and
salsa is an underrated bore four and I
expect him to score but if he doesn't
you know if the two fide Masters Nielsen
and mihalov can take care of business
don't count out Norway yet do not do not
do that that would be a huge mistake of
course we're getting closer and closer
to the big matchup that will happen at
the end of this show if you're just
joining us uh good news for you you
haven't missed too much
um because uh the
the matchup between Magnus Carlson and
Wesley so is is still is still Tech set
to take place uh we are uh
we're getting we're getting ready for
that uh and uh just uh checking on all
of our standings here I'm preparing to
bring up the uh the board the round
three standings
and uh here we go
um
so one point lead for the archbishops to
steal two more rounds to go anything can
happen we are all rooting for an eight
eight and we want to see a blitz playoff
absolutely
um mainly because we we're just
Adrenaline Junkies and when it comes to
the protest League I mean we've been
spoiled by some awesome chefs with not
very much time on the clock I just like
looking at this picture right here
because it gets me excited for the big
game we're gonna see I mean you know the
other argument is maybe maybe Magnus
beats Wesley so right I mean a Magnus is
supposed to be the best player in the
world and even though not many have been
able to do it so is human last time we
checked right there isn't a there isn't
a chip implanted there and so if if
Magnus can do what he's supposed to do
and if the bottom boards for Norway can
hold off the legendary Rose and salsa
with his sunglasses there then Norway is
not out of it yet but currently they
Trail by a game and they need to turn
things around if they're going to get
back in this match so we wait we wait
patiently right now for the next set of
games to start
yeah also for Magnus Carson I think this
is very personal at the same time so he
loves his team he's a a very good team
player but against Wesley so I think
that counts for him even more because
Wesley so won the Tata steel chess
tournament ahead of Magnus Carlsen and
for the pride of the world champion I
think that something that hurts
everybody's saying oh Wesley so oh
Wesley so Wesley hasn't lost the game
since June he won the grunches Tour he
won gold at the Olympiad he won the Tata
steel chest tournament now he's number
two in the world he must feel threatened
by Wesley
yeah you wonder I mean how much how much
personal Pride he takes into it right we
we highlight this matchup here I think
Magnus has surprised certainly chess.com
we've been thrilled with how much he's
loved the protest league and uh suddenly
he played one time and he caught the bug
and he's played every week since so
clearly he cares about his team winning
but Wesley as uh Wesley has been the
most consistent Elite Grand Master of
all of them so really I mean that that's
going to be the chance for Magnus to to
show that he's still number one and and
put Wesley back in his place so to speak
or or Wesley holds and his team wins and
it builds a potential rivalry that we're
all waiting for Wesley so and Magnus
Carlson so
and now he can have with Wesley as well
so yeah that would be great to see that
of course I think we all agree that
Magnus Carlson is the greatest chess
player at the moment but we want to see
that he has very close Rivals and
doesn't sit so comfortably on that
throne
yeah I mean just because it makes for
more drama right we want to see that
there are players capable without
playing him because the one thing that
separates Magnus I mean as we wait we
might as well talk about it the one
thing that separates Magnus is even when
Wesley wins that tournament and Magnus
Carlson Mr Mayton three for those of you
who remember against any Fury Magnus
still finished second and that's the
thing that has always separated him is
his consistency uh but we don't need to
talk anymore about the consistency
because right now the games are starting
and the first person on on his road to
maybe to maybe winning another game is
Magnus Carlson he is now White against
Grand Master varicobian and once again
is the exchange variation of the French
he did that yesterday against Maya and
he won easily uh in the blitz portion
but I I just thought this is a joke
Magnus costume refuting the French with
this line
Magnus Carlsen refutes the French with
refutes things with a lot of things we
don't expect right uh no but you're
right it's uh it's not the most common
thing you think of when you think
aggressive concrete approaches that the
uh you know that really put the French
in a struggle The Exchange is seen as
kind of boring I mean you look at the
structure it's completely symmetrical
totally equal
but it's the kind of game Magnus likes
right it's a small Edge based on the
slight a slight initiative and slightly
more active pieces and he feels like he
can outplay anybody from that type of
position so he goes for it once again
and if he outplayed uh Mayer Who is a
specialist not only in the French but
also in end games I think that means a
lot I agree I agree so we'll see if uh
Magnus can do it again by the way I see
some comments in the Chad Magnus did
have white again a second time yes he
just had white against Ben feingle now
he has white against varkovian but that
means he gets black against Wesley so so
that was actually I believe that the
colors were chosen Greg shahadi can can
confirm that in the chat but I believe
the colors were chosen by St Louis they
wanted to give Wesley so white when he
does take on Magnus Carls in the last
round so don't be too upset that Magnus
gets two whites in a row because that
means he gets black against the number
two player in the world pretty soon here
so okay
um Feingold is playing mihiloff here
what's what's going to happen we have uh
another symmetrical structure but but
this time some sort of kind of exchange
grunfeld or or something odd I don't
know what is it
which one I'm looking at the vine gold
game versus mihilov I think that uh we
had a we had a D4 D5 so started out with
a symmetrical Queen's Pawn game a G6
slaw ensued and white took the the road
of symmetrical structure here White's
only real edge here is a small
initiative that often leads to these
types of pony pops into the center
before black has full development uh the
reason this tactic the reason this
tactic happens everybody is if black
takes it the d-pawn becomes an issue
and if black doesn't take it this
exchange on C6 can sometimes lead to a
backward Pawn on the open file which
gives white some goals of where to put
this rook in and where to attack so a
quick insight into into some of the
things that happen in this structure
yeah these variations
at the elite level because all those
players who want to go for the not only
the slab but also the groom felt and
with white many times they try to avoid
their groom fat and the anti-groom fat
leads to the very same position so
we have seen this opening many times I
still find it boring but it could turn
into a slight Advantage for white
this and this move is interesting by
black this isn't a random shot the whole
point is he's he's anticipating that
white will capture here on C6 creating
the weak Pawn but he's he's done two
things here one he may try to play E5 if
white doesn't do anything to deal with
this Knight over here uh opening up
opening up the center opening up the
bishop maybe bringing this Knight back
but also in a lot of cases if the Knight
gets kicked it can head from H6 to F5
where suddenly the Knight Bishop have
new find uh Newfound hope of working
together against White Center so this
Knight to G4 idea as awkward as that may
seem for those who don't know the
opening is is actually a common idea for
black hero
um what do we move on to next the next
game has started between uh Grand Master
Grand Master Lee and Wesley so if
anybody besides Magnus Carlson has a
chance against Wesley so it's got to be
this guy right here right Norway's
number two with the white pieces if he
can do something like like get a draw
that might be a huge victory for Norway
and then of course we have the board
four Nicholas Rosen salsa taking on feed
a master Yoakam Nielsen this will also
be a huge game to watch this room
yeah as Mike Klein uh pointed it out in
the chat the only upset so far has been
uh Ben's draw against Lee
um I don't know if that was a big upset
because yes he is underrated but only
with like 50 70 rating points so there
hasn't been any real upset right so far
always the higher rated uh player won
the game but I don't think that will
stay like this in the last two rounds
I'm expecting at least some draws from
the underrated players right
yeah well we'll see I think uh I think
if if unfortunately for Norway if all
goes to plan and there are no upsets I
think that Trends in in the direction of
St Louis right because of of their two
grand Masters on boards two and three
versus Norway's only one on board two uh
not not counting of course the super GM
so and Carlson so um
you know I think that if Lee can do
something against so in this round and
if the feeding Masters can prove that
they're not gonna let Rosen salsa out of
his cage keep the youngster down that
will be the key for Norway let's go back
to magnus's game against the Kobe and we
see this exchange French
kind of like a boring variation of the
Berlin too this is like two boring
openings had a baby and their baby is
also boring big surprise right two
boring openings had a baby and it didn't
change much so this is just a boring
position uh I started to like it for
white I was going to say that I don't
find it boring anymore why why is this
not boring there's nothing going on here
why does why does uh beautiful night on
E5 and you have just managed to push F4
so black is struggling to finish
development you cannot push the beep on
the C6 Pawn is always hanging and you
don't want to take on E5 so how do you
develop the C8 Bishop well my idea was I
could play 98 and F6 but maybe I'm
realizing that you're right because 98
and F6 may be too slow if it opens up
tactics on the G6 Square
um yeah perhaps he should move away the
D7 Knight and then but yeah even then
where do you place the bishop on E6 it's
too passive and uh he will have to do
something against this E5 Knight
uh
uh you're right I'm wrong big surprise
yeah if it's not as boring it's boring
from the perspective that it was the
strategical you know sub symmetry right
and and we didn't see a lot of crazy
tactics but as we said this is kind of
like what Magnuson Magnus wants right to
prove that when the advantages are
really small and the most accuracy is
required in order to squeeze water out
of the stone Magnus Carlson does it
better than anybody right
um and exactly and look at his time he
hasn't used not even a minute for this
position and that kobian is under 10
minutes yeah he makes it why can't just
be so easy how does Madness make
everything look so easy I could play and
exchange French and put my knight on E5
Anna you don't believe me I can do this
why does he how does he make it look so
easy seriously I don't know Danny maybe
it's that you don't want to trade queens
and play a boring position I love
trading Queens I'm not the old I'm not
the old attacker I used to be no I mean
it's amazing though he just he just
plays a position that is like super
simple yeah and and develops naturally
and and has an initiative that suddenly
looks
looks a lot harder to play for black I
feel like Magnus Carlsen has made me a
better chess player by making me realize
that maybe chesk isn't as hard as I've
been making it forever now I've yet to
put that theory
I love that he plays like this a very
human chest that Magnus Carson is
playing
so it's great to see that yeah you can
play The Exchange French for a win Peter
Doggers is writing in the chat about it
that Magnus Carlsen is the other world
champion besides Gary Kasparov who plays
The Exchange French for a win with the
white pieces
yeah in Grand Master Christian uh
carilla also saying that Magnus has tons
of experience in this symmetrical
position so things that seem close to
equal and maybe little idiosyncrasies
that we don't recognize right away of
course he sees much more quickly uh
Grandmaster Lee is in a a theoretical
position here against Grandmaster Wesley
so now that doesn't mean I know the
theory I just know that it's theoretical
so don't hold that against me
um but okay it's a position where white
probably has a small Edge but but
nothing really to write home about yet
uh I must admit I don't have a clue
about this opening so uh
yeah no idea maybe next time the players
will let us know what openings they're
playing ahead of time so we can yeah
they could have written us a whole
lot it would make us not look as foolish
as we look but uh no so we so we just
try to describe what's going on I mean
you see black with this isolated Pawn
everybody but the difference between
this iqp isolated Queen Pawn uh and and
like the game we were talking about
where Feingold had an edge against it is
that here white doesn't have an open
file for one to focus efforts against
the pawn and two it white lacks any real
solid coordinated effort I mean this
Pawn is is potentially a renegade any
moment here right so this is this is not
so simple for white there's also the C
for C4 Square I think a move like Knight
C4 would be met by Bishop to B4 from
Grand Master Lee he'd look to Castle and
then as soon as he can try to start
coordinating toward the queen side and
and undermine this Pawn but um
but it's not the most traditional
position where you look at this isolated
Queen pawn and say oh that's an obvious
weakness it's not such an obvious
weakness
David is supporting us in the chat he
says that we would just need ear pieces
and somebody feeding us Theory
earpieces and feeding us theory that
sounds like a good idea except it'd
probably be I'm already multitasking you
know
you know technical team management and
server support and the show I think I
think one more thing would I'd rather
just look like an idiot I think than
actually have one more thing to do
um
all right well okay White's gonna play
Knight E4 I assume is there any reason
why the Knight goes to A4 or another
okay no he goes to E4 no 90 for a very
normal move and Knight D6 could be
coming as well if you attack this Knight
with Bishop F5 uh and I'm once again
blundering why I'm blundering all my
Rooks today Danny I don't know why
you're blundering your books today maybe
we'll talk about it later but definitely
something to think about uh the main the
main thing is is uh remember that a
successful result for white here is
definitely a draw in terms of the match
setting like someone has to slow down so
who's not named Magnus Carlson yeah
right now I like Lee's position a little
bit he's a little better
um but but we'll see if we'll see if so
can find a way to to equalize but not
allow all the pieces to be traded Bishop
F5 I think white will play D3 right yeah
or he can play Knight H4 as well if he
wants to force the trade but perhaps
these three is better so you also
prevent the black pushing D3
I like D3 because we're also we're not
worried about double pawns here
everybody yeah so I would have the
bishop here and um you know honestly
these double pawns are kind of strong
they hold they hold some key squares and
it opens the D file for the pawn so that
would be something black would want okay
so so plays Knight C4 and we see Bishop
to B4 immediately as we anticipated
um
okay things going well
uh
the uh let's check on the next game
we've got we've got uh the board four
battle uh Rosen Rosen salsa versus
Nielsen
um
quiet at an early stage what I was
checking now is the band's position and
uh I like that Knight on C5 a lot I
don't know if it makes much
it's a beautiful Outpost but he has an a
backward E3 pawn and uh yeah so it has
its advantages and disadvantages that he
went for this position
yeah it seems like one where white is
white is initially you know optically
looks very happy solo Knight bad Bishop
behind you know it's the classical bad
Bishop we Define as one that's exactly
locked in but then but then you look at
it E3 is weak B3 is is currently being
held back
the look for tactics on D5 I wonder
sometimes if we should be aware of that
what white would really like is to get
B4 and B5 and try to undermine and open
up some weaknesses here but but black is
currently doing his best to prevent B4
um
yes A5 is an important move as you
mentioned to prevent B4
and uh I always want to blunder my Rooks
I was going to say Rook B5 but then
Bishop takes D5 works
so don't blunder your Rook
yeah definitely Pro tip Pro tip from
International Master Rudolph don't
blunder your Rook
um exactly it's very important that
chess that you don't blunder Rooks in
one move all right no I mean uh good yep
yep I hear you
um okay so let's go check on uh let's go
back to rosenthal's game uh the board
for
and let's just try to understand what
happens here before it gets too messy I
like the way Rosenthal is playing he's
undermined the D5 Pawn with the goal
that okay it's not just about winning
the pawn it's about opening up the
diagonal of this very strong Bishop
um it looks like now black has to make a
decision do I continue to try to defend
that pawn and and you know we're in a
steering contest or do I have to break
do I have to push or capture I feel like
black is going to have to break here and
do something about that pawn
so how would you do it well I mean you
can't play Bishop E6 because the E5 Pawn
is hanging right from The Rook I think
so so that makes me think well how would
I do it well I don't like D4 that self
blocks my own bishop and this bishop
feels feels kind of frisky
um taking C4 feels like we're headed
toward a better end game for white where
White's three on two is much more
effective than Black's doubled four on
three so this this doesn't feel good
either and so like I said I I like the
position of the young Rosenthal I'm
refraining from calling him Rose and
salsa because I was informed by my team
that maybe that's an inside joke that
not enough people get so we'll stop
calling him Rose and salsa okay he plays
for Bishop E6 sorry to interrupt you but
this was the move that we were saying
that it's not possible there must be
zero tactics on F2 whenever I look at
Rook takes E5 I'm immediately assuming
maybe there's some sort of trick that
involves a discovery but I don't I don't
see anything here
I guess his plan on Rook takes E5 must
be to capture on C4 and just blow the
doors open on the position
probably and also the B7 phone will be
hanging in the end so well massive
exchanges
yeah so what happens at the end of those
massive exchanges let's just take take
shake and bake Bishop takes B7
who's who's winning and why I I don't uh
very very tricky the moves are probably
about to be played faster than we can
calculate them yeah exactly they are
going for this Rook takes E5 now D takes
D takes and I think Bishop takes C4
should be played before trading anything
on D1 of course and maybe this was the
right approach for black because we were
sort of highlighting the struggle of
guarding the D5 Pawn or E5 and so even
if he ends up being down a pawn and I'll
just throw it out there like is a
position like this like is it the end of
the world for black maybe not right
there's some pressure the Bishops are
it's it's not like white is just
instantly winning here black is probably
going to have some pressure on on some
critical points in this position yes
he's got good practical chances so it
was a good decision by Nielsen
uh what about the other games because I
feel like we will miss something if we
stay at this position
um
everyone loves Magnus he's
he's not one yet he's continuing to show
that he's he's good in these really very
small Advantage positions what's changed
since we were last here everybody is
black now has an isolated Pawn that he
didn't have before but you got to kind
of like a Kobe's position right he went
from being undeveloped and worries on
the e-file too at least all of his
pieces are out and the d-pawn isn't the
easiest Pawn to go win
look at that instantly responds yeah B4
11 min and that kobia three what has he
calculated to play this so fast he's
calculated that he's gonna go get the D4
Pawn Black's gonna win a two but he's
gonna end in the line with Knight to F5
look at this
if the bishop moves to D5 Knight takes
D4 Bishop takes A2 Knight F5 and White's
pieces are
are bringing the pressure
yes and the other option is Bishop to E8
but that's very passive right it doesn't
feel doesn't feel very happy to put your
Bishop on the a but maybe that's what a
code he went for it but I just think
that wise position is is great
um exchange French but it doesn't look
like a French anymore yeah and this week
the four Pawn should fall also Black's
pieces are are really passive so I'm I
think that Magnus will win this
comfortably how about Wesley is he
getting an advantage
uh
white is still not castled so the
position is opening up a little bit and
and uh tactics are coming
oh we should be sick so these night
jumps are suddenly very dangerous yeah
it makes you wonder how is how is black
dealing with some sort of night jump
into G5 to undermine this piece just
just move the bishop to D5 perhaps
uh
yeah where do you go with the queen if
you want to get out of this diagonal
yeah it's strange I wonder so the last
move by Lee he played Queen to B3
probably thinking the same way we were
about you know Bishop E6 was going to
run into some Knight G5 moves but uh
maybe he underestimated a simple move of
the bishop to a safe Square
the queen doesn't have a lot of good
options to get away from discovered
attacks here
no I don't like the fact that if he goes
Queen a for them black could play A6
opening the a file well we're gonna find
out right so Lee is all in right he's
pot committed with this idea he plays
Knight G5 I think we're gonna see so
just play Bishop D5 and then I have a
hard time liking White's position
because H6 is coming The Rook is open on
the e-file and I feel like getting
castled is gonna run into some sort of
discovery
yeah this is really bad for life so then
the night jump now is a huge threat and
also F5
and maybe even H6 just a simple yeah oh
that night on G5 and
isn't he just lost isn't white lost here
well I I don't see like a concrete
resigned move but I do I'm feeling more
and more that Queen B3 was premature I
think that at hindsight uh lee would
have much preferred just getting castled
in this position back on move 15. get
the king out of the center avoid avoid
the craziness of what's about to ensue I
mean honestly even if he had just
castled Anna and then been able to play
a move like Pawn D3 get the Knight on e4
some protection kick this Knight out
that would have been a way for white to
it feels like white maintains a small
Edge there
oh we underestimated some tactics Knight
D6 what in the world oh my gosh is this
working
um well he took a lot of time on his
clock so it better be working because
he's got three minutes to 10 minutes
this is uh this is either
either brilliant or losing on the spot
either brilliant you're losing on the
spot likely right it's where I like to
live my life
On The Edge on the edge of failure all
the time uh the
okay so the obvious tactics here
everybody the ideas is white has
unleashed the bishop to attack here and
though you're giving up the bishop if
Queen takes C4 is played
suddenly there's all kinds of action
here on F7 uh where this Rook might be
poisoned to some sort of mating net
captures and who knows you just move the
queen and and something nasty happens
the problem I have with Lee's combo is
after takes here what if I come back to
D5 after gobbling the bishop
and then you take the pieces and then I
start taking the pieces I okay I have
Knight G takes F7 if I'm Lee there Anna
um and if Bishop takes C4 I get to take
the queen and and it's actually okay but
but maybe after Knight takes F7 again
you just move the queen and white still
has to deal with this bishop on D5
exactly
yeah I feel like I feel like I wanna I
wanna call the bluff here and Wesley so
is obviously trying to play like us he
plays Bishop takes G2 and I'm gonna
guess that he intends to meet Queen
takes C4 with the exact move we just
said Bishop to D5 yeah so the other
option is Knight takes E8 here but I'm
not buying this at all
mm-hmm also he's got only three minutes
Lee agree totally and I think again I
feel like this is what happens when good
good positions can go bad quickly with
one inaccuracy a white plays the move
Queen B3
um and you know something went wrong
because after B Bishop E6 in these
several moves he ends up taking a lot of
time on his clock coming up with this
mess of a mess of an idea but
uh
doesn't look like it's going to deliver
anything concrete so I I feel like
White's best chances were were before he
committed to this idea and just got
canceled yeah let's go let's go see
what's going on in Ben's game ooh Black
is Black is getting active and Ben's
game upset alert I like Black's position
here against Grand Master Feingold this
is a very strange
hmm so how did this all happen he
dropped the E3 Pawn
I I don't know how let's see how he
dropped the e-pawn um maybe he he just
couldn't protect it
because he's committed because he got
his Knight trapped on on C5 sort of
right and it was very smart to play King
age Aid because this rugby five is the
move I wanted to play but with the King
on G8 it was not working because
everything takes D5 blundering
c65. so remember Anna's tip
exactly yeah no the point everybody is
this Rook survives because of the
protection so this move King h8 was very
very uh had a lot of foresight good
prophylactic thinking that put Feingold
in an awkward spot having to guard the
Knight and the pawn
he he commits to holding the C file but
with it he loses the E Pawn now we're
getting a bunch of moves where
it doesn't seem like white should really
be able to expect a win in this game
anymore which has got to be gotta make
Norway feel good if they can work their
way back into the match in one of their
FMS can pull an upset against GM
Feingold questions are being asked of
course what are we doing to monitor the
players and how do we ensure that the
protest league has been so awesome and
completely Fair all of the players right
now including Magnus Carlson no no
players are accepted or exceptions to
this rule are being monitored by webcam
we have an entire Team guys that work
for chess.com on their staff are
actually in Skype calls with every
player right now uh some of the players
are even being asked to do screen share
while doing webcam uh and of course our
our methods that are based much on much
more advanced things than just whether
you look at somebody
um statistics and all kinds of stuff
that we can't really talk about so
um you know we have we have uh we are
very very confident that whoever wins
the pro Chesley will have done so fairly
and so uh thank you for asking but all
the players right now our underwear our
under webcam review and that helps a lot
just like the speed Chess Championship
having everybody being watched allows us
to monitor some things and then of
course we do all kinds of analysis to
ensure that things were played fairly so
okay let's let's keep going here um go
back to Magnus carlsen's game because he
has won already oh my gosh this one is
going crazy I mean it was already crazy
but we have to keep on looking at it so
I keep missing his
I keep missing I know he's too quick
he's too quick this game wow how many
moves did they play in the last 30
seconds exactly and he doesn't use his
time he's got nine minutes on the clock
when his opponent resigns
combination we started Anna we got to
get there faster sorry go ahead and
interrupt me I I I'm sorry I missed the
end here but he he launched this plan of
bringing the Knight to F5 anyway we were
talking about this idea and then
so why the position was still a little
bit unclear this is a bishop here but he
just recognizes he's better in The Rook
ending because of the more active King
really instructive to see not all Rook
endings are drawn Magnus knows that an
active King is a huge Advantage
especially when the counterpart just
really is struggling to get active
um now he now he plays a little tickle
wins upon outright
um and goes on to squeeze the Rook
ending something tells me with best play
Black might have had better drawing
chances than a Kobe and got but okay I'm
not gonna I'm not gonna be too picky
Magnus goes on to win uh wins The Rook
ending easily now he's about to get a
queen amazing stuff Magnus Carlson
everybody is currently 3-0 on his way to
helping the Gnomes get back in this
match
yeah it's actually so as well although
the position is still crazy of course
after this Knight D6 move Bishop takes
G2 Knight takes F7 was played there
yeah this is where we left it but I
think that was all just these are sort
of desperate attempts by a desperate man
right I mean I think I think he feels
like that yeah I think Lee knew that
this combination was bogus he's doing
something to mix it up
but one thing Wesley so doesn't do very
often is blunder
and
um
let's see best best case scenario white
is white has a rook against two minor
pieces which we would like Wesley so if
he just backs up the bishop to D5 uh
maybe there's something even better for
him there
um
so I'm saying best case scenario for
Grand Master Lee he's worse in a two
miners versus Rook thing but maybe
Wesley is trying to calculate if there's
something even better than just the
obvious Bishop back to D5
yeah this is definitely looking very bad
for white
desperate and he's got one minute left
what about the other two boards because
it seems that Magnus and Wesley are
still winning all their games and what
depends what uh will actually decide the
result is what happens on the other
board
yeah and and on that note we got to go
to the game that we we said seems to be
trending in the direction of an upset
Grandmaster Ben Feingold down a pawn
black really really active with the
Rooks on the third rank
so this is this is not going well for
Grand Master Feingold right now for sure
not at all black is dominating the
position so it's a pawn up and very
active pieces I'll have to C5 then C4
Yep this is looking very bad
unless
oh my gosh I just made it
black just black just made it himself
no oh my gosh look at that the H file
she absolutely unbelievable black was
grinding black was grinding down the
game he grabs the C file thinking it's
good technique but he he actually just
walked into this combination any other
move here you know he can try to get the
king out and he's fine but Anna he plays
C5 and now he's losing a piece if a if
King H7 he's gonna be mated on the H
file me
unbelievable suddenly the tables have
turned and Ben Feingold is back in the
game that was nuts
it's a it was a one move trick and it
was a one movement not only that it was
a one move trick that black invited
right it's not it's not even something
but that's why he missed it because
black isn't even thinking about that
here because he owns the B file yeah
C3 to prepare C5 to prepare C5 and and
but unfortunately walks himself right
into this idea again everybody black is
winning the FM was on his way to an
upset against the GM if he does
something like this just get the king
safe and then go back to your funky town
and push in the pawns but instead
that is just that that could be the
match right there I mean because in
order for Norway to win they needed
upsets
they needed somebody to score against
the the two and three boards the GM's
final Cobian but now exactly no I think
this is that's a that is a huge
turnaround
um
Feingold is going to go on to win this
he doesn't even want the Rook with the
Knight apparently that's kind of
surprising I would have just gobbled up
The Rook I'm maybe I'm just a little bit
more greedy
but I why did he not just take the Rook
with the Knight I don't know yeah I
think that was easily winning I don't
know takes and then uh his Rook was
hanging on D7
okay well he's he's trying to have oh
his work was hanging on D7 duh that's
why so I was meaning don't hang Rooks I
forgot Anna's number one team yeah
um you should pay attention to Our Only
Rule that's right so uh so Ben doesn't
Ben doesn't uh fall for that but
seriously a heartbreaking game right now
I mean look at the time too Anna Ben is
down Ben was in a lost position with
less than 30 seconds on the clock and
his opponent handed him the gift of the
protest League Championship and if
Feingold goes on to win this game that
may be it I I mean the Bishops may have
gotten that much closer to locking up
the title
this is crazy stuff I still can't
believe this blunder by me I love
okay so let's check on board four then I
mean it's not over really but I I just
can't believe that blunder that was a
chance for Norway to take the driver's
seat now Nielsen seems to be out playing
Rosenthal so that that is good news for
uh for the Norway fans
black has the bishop pair
um you know I think I think an
aggressive okay that blunders a piece
after B5
how was that a good idea what happened
sorry I missed that part Rosenthal just
played Bishop takes A4
and after B5 I think he thought he had
Rook to see
two I mean in the wrong position so I
didn't see that
look at this amazing combo if Rook C2
Bishop takes B4 he has Rook takes C4
Intermezzo saving the day
so is that what Rosenthal yeah he played
Rook C2 I think I think Nielsen felt the
same way that this must be losing for
white with so many pieces tied up but
but actually maybe white is swindling
his way out of a bad position here
it could be but it's such a weird
position I was looking at this bishop on
A4 it it is not only attacked it's also
trapped uh on Mike is informing us that
uh Wesley so has one on time already his
position was winning and he eventually
won on time no surprise there as we said
Grandmaster Lee was on his way
unfortunately to uh trying to justify
this bogus combination
um disappointing for the Gnomes this
game not necessarily a huge surprise so
wins but obviously
um checking on the game with Ben
Feingold it's not over I guess
especially given that feingle only has
10 seconds but but certainly mihilov was
in a much better case than he's in now
and I do expect Ben to win this game so
that means in order for Norway to even
stay in the match
Nielsen needs to win here but he's not
going to in fact now he may lose
crazy stuff happening now in the protest
league and
and basically we have seen such upsets
and blunders that
I think yep no seriously this is this
was this was a huge turnaround here uh
this game was this game was also at
least blacks blacks to at least get a
draw I mean black was in the driver's
seat here
um but Rosenthal very resourceful he he
came up with this very tricky idea to
save the day based on Rook takes C4 that
I think that's what Nielsen probably
missed
and uh and wow wow wow and uh it looks
like in fact
on that note Feingold has one
has really oh well no sorry I'm not I'm
excited yeah I'm confusing things
because he was lost and then he won yeah
it wins I still can't believe it but he
won
absolutely ridiculous as Ben himself
says in the chat
um
he uh he is just absolutely ridiculous
Ben was blend Ben was lost about 20
moves ago when with no time on the clock
the tables turned with one massive
blunder
unfortunately putting the Gnomes really
up against the wall headed into the last
round they may have to pull a sweep
we'll see they're they're down no
they'll be down three points if
Rosenthal can win this game here which
now he's on his way to doing so so this
is this is a really big moment here if I
guess if yokim Nielsen draws then he's
then they're only then they're still
only down two points and and that's a
much easier deficit
then three that that just feels like
impossible although we have seen that
previously when the Gnomes only needed I
think a point in one round in the last
round against the Delhi dynamite and and
they could not they almost did not do it
because they were worse in every
position in every game
so it can happen but that that would be
really really tough to get back from a
three-point deficit
well it looks like they're headed that
way a three-point deficit would be
um would be required would require the
sweep
um by by uh Norway in the last round and
it looks like that's where they're
headed really really huge turn of events
in this round
um the upsets were there they had them
in hand especially as far as uh
Nielsen's game he was much better in
mihiloff's game but but St Louis
they proved why they are uh they're
they're experienced in this online team
format they did not lose their cool
found some resourceful tricks and I
expect Rosenthal to win this game
and with it basically put Norway against
the wall down three points headed into
the last round
guys if you are
please use the hashtag protest I've just
seen that Anton squared me already has a
cute gift for the finals I'm not sure
that it's the correct one though it's a
gnome beating up an Archbishop sort of
and maybe it's the other way around
yeah
um well uh everybody loves Anton's
Anton's Photoshop work at least
sometimes I do
um but no it's uh definitely fun he's a
fun follow on Twitter but seriously Anna
that that may have been the match right
there and and you know I know we both
had St Louis as being favored but the
truth is you never know and in that
situation I think if a couple of these
results Go a different way
you're looking at something totally
different head in the last round now it
will take a miracle comeback by the
Gnomes they're down three points with
one round of play they gotta sweep
I mean
three and a half pounds I think
everything is possible but uh
I feel like psychologically they are
already
uh pretty much done of course they will
try to do their best but they are
missing two of their best players hammer
and tari
um it's a very tough situation three
points behind and not having those two
Grandmasters so basically the Gnomes
usually played with their Olympic team
cause and Hammer and Tori and now this
is the the B team I would say right
unfortunate that they weren't able to to
field their A-Team in this in this
Championship but scheduling difficulties
I think next year uh given how much
everyone has just shown to care so much
about this they will probably maybe go
out of their way to make sure that
doesn't happen and that everybody's
available should they make the finals uh
but uh not taking anything away from St
Louis they have fielded their A-Team
pretty much the lineup they used
whenever they could is the lineup you're
looking at with so a Kobe and Feingold
and Rosenthal and uh and they are
proving they are proving why they are
the favorites
um we are we are going to start the next
round here within about five minutes
everybody so don't go anywhere of course
the big matchup that will start first
and foremost is the one between Magnus
Carlson and Wesley so Carlson will be up
against it with the black pieces against
the number two player in the world uh
not going to be easy but he has to do
something he certainly can't lose if he
loses it's it's over but if he if he
wins and gives his team a Fighting
Chance who knows what happens on the
other boards stranger things have
happened
uh but uh but right now the gnomes are
up against it Anna and we could be
headed toward a a crowning of the Saint
Louis archbishops as the champion
I'm still rooting for the eight eight so
go gnomes please I'd like to see the
blitz playoff
yeah I agree of course we all want the
blitz playoff um
but uh but I don't know I doesn't don't
know if it's if it's destined to be in
the cards this time around of course we
are now ready for the round for pairings
as you can see we will have Grand Master
Wesley soaping playing white Jacobian
going against Grand Master Lee fine gold
against Nielsen and Rosenthal against
mihiloff
um
starting soon don't go anywhere the pro
Chesley Championship is not over yet the
biggest match up at least on paper as
far as the players go is so versus
Carlson and you haven't missed that it's
about to start
and uh Ann and I will have the call see
what these two players have in store for
us here hopefully not a boring draw no
nobody looking for some sort of
concession that this match is over
anything can happen in a team event and
I think Magnus will be all out for for
blood in this game despite having black
I agree that he he will go all in for
his team so he has to do it and if he
wins as you said the Gnomes could still
somehow uh turn this event which is not
looking very good for them three points
behind this is the last round they need
to score
tons of points so
uh yeah I'm very bad at them
how do they do it I mean let's say
Carlson beats so let's just say because
it's possible yeah let's say that let's
say that Lee manages to beat a Kobe on
right so then which one of these FMS is
more likely to win definitely Sebastian
mihilafi should be favored against
Rosenthal
um
but uh
but uh you know I I expect flying gold
to do well uh against against Nielsen I
I but you know we'll see I think that uh
Feingold got away with one in the last
in the last game as he would admit uh
but
but now now he's favored once again a
fresh game new start nothing else
matters so uh
Norway's got to be all in maybe the
psychological approach from St Louis
Anna is to know that their opponents
have to be all in be solid right take a
take a calculated uh approach right
maybe not something that's too Dynamic
and and let let them have to push a
position that maybe should be equal into
something crazy and see if they get
themselves in trouble that's one of the
big advantages of having a lead like
this
yeah I think that that would be a great
strategy and probably that's what we
will see that they go solid vesely is
usually very solid against the Magnus so
that would not be a surprise but perhaps
that's what they will do on the other
boards as well and as for the Norwegians
they have to go all in it doesn't matter
if they lose uh with a big difference
these finals or just a point they have
to try to at least equalize the score
they have to aim for the eight eight
absolutely well the games will be
starting and count them just a few
seconds so if you're just joining us go
get your friends you are about to see
Wesley cell versus Magnus Carlson this
is the pro chess League finals this is
the last round right now this is for the
championship everything is on the line
and we are starting Magnus Carlson
versus Wesley so in three two one
liftoff here we go so this is our big
matchup Wesley so takes a few seconds to
consider his approach against the world
champion
D4 no surprise uh this game will be
starting and then a few minutes here
we'll have all the other games started
of course but we're going to give this
one our full attention because it's what
everyone pays money for right here yeah
the number one and the number two in the
world against each other right now in
the protest League the last time they
faced each other was the Tata steel
chess tournament in January and Wesley
was playing with the white pieces it
ended up in a draw but it doesn't mean
that today it will not be an eventful
gay Magnus Carson has to go for
something crazy
starts out with a nimzo now what's funny
is I wonder what kind of preparation
they're thinking is in this game if they
have something that they like to play in
these openings based on the time control
uh if Wesley so is thinking about what
he likes to play in this opening when he
knows a draw is a good result is white
or or are they are they just going on
you know really well prepared Theory
anything they know that they can do to
to surprise their opponent right because
the thing about people to people don't
understand about players of that level
is that preparation is it's not just
based on
what what they've analyzed with the
engines and know is their best approach
a lot of it they have many different
approaches and they kind of choose the
line they like based on the
circumstances right exactly
seeing yeah that's what Magnus is doing
right now choosing the BOGO Indian with
A5
yeah absolutely he's uh he's he's taking
on a
it's it's not a it's not a super offbeat
line but this A5 line is designed to
kind of mix up things very early it's
not the most commonly most common uh
leap played approach against the Queen's
Indian these days yeah we've got some
info thanks to Mike so we do have the
experts uh working behind the scenes
he's saying that every time Wesley had
the white pieces against Magnus it was a
draw except for Von Blitz game so uh
usually Wesley is very solid against
Magnus not aiming for anything sharp and
accepts the draw
um also Magnus said that in an interview
at the Tata steel chess tournament that
this is how Wesley's style is he
believes that when he's facing somebody
stronger and now there's only one player
stronger than Wesley
um he would normally accept the draw
that's what Magnus said
well I think it's true right it's also I
mean if if you feel confident in your in
your preparation and you can get
something that puts the onus on your
opponent to push for a win you play
solidly and see what happens right if
they give you an opportunity you take it
otherwise you're you're just sort of
holding your ground
um this is all Theory so far everybody
you know black is going to put this
bishop on either B7 or A6 both are
possible
um and okay he goes for B7 in many cases
this this becomes a difficult one for
black to get too much in the center
because you want to use this E4 Square
for the Knight but that's going to lead
to another exchange so this is just a
very solid approach by white uh and and
we're going to reach a middle game where
I expect black to get castled probably
play something with like D6 and maybe
develop the Knight
um I don't expect him to play Bishop
takes F3 but maybe he'll do something
crazy because he wants to create make it
as Dynamic and awkward as possible we'll
see who knows
yeah um this uh this is very solid uh
not a surprise the second game has just
started between Captain Casanova and
Frolic 67 so mihaila versus Rosenthal
D4 is on the board and we are waiting
for Rosenthal to make his response right
well big game right here I mean I think
for for Norway to mount their comeback
uh this game has to go in the favor of
Norway mihiloff has to win this game as
white for sure and I think Magnus
Carlson honestly has to win as black as
difficult as the task as that is right
playing the playing the black pieces
against someone not only number two in
the world but as we've just been talking
about Wesley so style it's just not that
indicative of giving Carlson a lot of
winning chances right he doesn't it's
not like the Nakamura Carlson battle
where you know it's going to be random
and decisive often in the Norwegians
favor but still uh it's it's just it's
going to be super solid from from White
and he's going to really make Magnus
work for something Dynamic and weird
so okay next games are starting here we
also have the game uh oh no not quite
yet right now we're still waiting for uh
fine Gold's game versus uh feeding
Master Nielsen and Grand Master Lee
versus Grand Master okobian Okay
um sorry Danny I was wondering if
Rosenthal is experiencing some kind of
an internet connection problem because
he is not making moves very quickly he's
not I think he was just thinking he just
played right now but one and a half
minute for two moves
I mean uh yeah I don't know he was
trying he was trying to decide what he
wanted to play uh it's maybe
an interesting approach from Rosenthal
who I think should be settled with like
a with a draw I mean this is this Dutch
uh extension of the F Pawn
this is gonna personally I really enjoy
playing white in these systems I think
that white gets really nice comfortable
middle games as long as you go for
something that strikes on the light
squares against the Dutch but a strange
approach from me to me for black when
probably he didn't need to go for
something something so weird but okay
now now maybe we got a stone wall uh
mihiloff decides to play E3 instead of
the more typical Dutch approach for
white which is usually something like G3
everybody because when this bishop comes
to this diagonal that helps whites
attempts to strike in the center on the
light Square so okay interesting E3 and
B6 not something
this is a weird opening and I'm liking
Rosenthal more and more because black uh
didn't play
because white didn't play the more
traditional approach so okay interesting
stuff back in Magnus Carson's game uh
Peter Douglas is informing us that uh
magnus's nice move Knight E4 was a
theoretical novelty so look at that how
seriously they take the protest League
theoretical novelty by Magnus Carlsen
and uh after after establishing A4
that's a nice move to to hold back
expansion on the queen side it also you
know maybe he'll he'll try to use the A5
Square for a knight uh that maybe poke
some poke some fun at these light
squares here and and try to go after the
C Pawn I think white still has a small
Edge in these positions you know white
has a space Advantage sometimes you look
for a shot with D5 if you're white and
the idea everybody is that in some cases
if black takes it you can move this
Knight and and try to continue to put
pressure on the pin here but uh
okay we'll see what happens the next
game has now begun let's take a look at
Grand Master or kobian versus Lee or
let's not because they haven't moved yet
Grand Master Feingold versus feeding
Master Nielsen we have another London
system this time sorry now that you
mentioned that a copying is now making a
move I've just recalled that yesterday
he was having serious trouble with his
internet connection so I don't know
what's going on in St Louis but uh maybe
they might lose the match because they
cannot connect to the game I I would
doubt that to be happened but doubt that
to happen but hopefully they can handle
that I mean worst case scenario just you
know turn on a hot spot from your phone
or something I have no idea St Louis not
the place where you would normally
expect them to have those kind of
technical difficulties
um
but okay let's see let's go back to
magnus's game with so this is the one
that most people thinking about more
simplification from Wesley making it
very difficult for Carlson to create
something that has winning chances
um I know Magnus is probably frustrated
that Wesley is taking this approach but
that's what Wesley does and uh
it's gonna be hard for black to get
winning chances here I mean we've
already seen three minor pieces traded
off right
yeah uh this I think will head towards a
draw and that means that the archbishops
would only need another draw from the
other three gates
exactly so gonna make it difficult if
Carlson can't do something here but a
tall task as we've said having black
against so and his style
um
okay so the board four match up this has
become a very weird stone wall where I I
just like Black's approach I mean Bishop
E2 Bishop F3 I didn't like the approach
to go into the Dutch but I I can't be in
favor of White's White's choice of of uh
of how to play against the Dutch
it's it's pretty weird
yeah I don't uh
I don't get it but okay
that's it so let's continue to roll on
we have a Cobian getting himself in
another benoni
apparently he likes these positions as
white but now taking on Grand Master Lee
rather than one of the feeding Masters
we'll see if that changes the the way
this one goes of course we already saw a
very very nice exchange sack by a Kobe
and if you're just joining us you missed
a brilliant win uh by The Armenian
American Grand Master earlier in this
match
H3 is a typical move everybody mainly
because white doesn't like black getting
rid of this Knight and that kind of
increases Black's long-term control over
these dark squares so that's why you see
H3 in these openings
um
okay so they're moving quickly the
benoni continues H3 also a multi-purpose
move because it opens up this Square for
the bishop sorry Anna what were you
saying
no no uh nothing
gone oh okay I was gonna I was gonna pop
back over and check on Carlson's ability
or lack thereof to get winning chances
against so
okay so you know this is just it's not
the most exciting game but you know the
what Magnus has to hope for if he's
trying to win his black is that if the
tension maintains itself long enough he
gets an end game where there's
opportunities to go wrong in time
pressure and everybody everybody makes
those types of mistakes we could sit
here and talk ourselves blue in the face
and try to convince you there's some
long-term winning chances like if this
Knight reaches B3 and b2's weak or
something but the truth is it's a very
equal position no real strategical
weaknesses for either side E4 is an
aggressive move I mean that was that was
an aggressive approach there by by white
so
um we could see some action start to
happen here on the king side
yeah what I like about Wesley is that
he's very pragmatic so
um yes probably he would not mind to
make a draw in this game especially
since his team would be winning the
protest league with that draw probably
but if the position is an advantage for
why then he will play for that Advantage
well I think he has a similar a similar
psychological point of view to chess
that Magnus Carlson does which is you
take what the position gives you and
exactly try to bring as little emotional
bias into what you want into the
position I think that
um Wesley so and Magnus Carlson are very
similar in that they they have that
really really lethal mindset that is
that they have short-term memory they
don't remember their mistakes they just
operate with Supreme confidence and they
take very uh pragmatic approaches to the
game if they're better they'll push on
even if the tournament says they should
take a draw if they're worse they'll go
for a draw even if it says they should
go for a win because they do what the
position tells them to do it's a good
lesson for everybody I for one Emma
complete Basket Case play way too
emotional chess and I can never practice
what I preach I'm just really good at
talking let's go to the next game
um okay so this stone wall has become
just nuts I mean black gets everything
he wants in this game Anna Rosenthal has
a knight on e4
white doesn't have
the kind of approach you normally get to
pry open the light squares with F3 and
E4
I just you know again I'm kind of
overreacting and to say it's not like
white is really worse here these
positions are roughly equal but just not
the not the principled approach you
normally take to the Dutch you punish a
movement of the f-pawn just like you
would tell kids by prying open those
light squares and punishing them for
such positional insolence
uh yeah now he goes H4 preventing G5
which would happen almost dropped a
piece for white so it's it's good that
he's preventing G5 right
but it's still a bit weird I agree with
you
yeah I like I like Rosenthal code but
this is going to be a while before we
get anything too Dynamic let's see
what's going on with fine golden Nielsen
this one seems to be moving along more
quickly than the others oh this is
looking very Jewish
yeah a lot of pieces coming off the
board symmetrical I mean smart play by
Feingold to let it be Josh because his
his team is in the driver's seat
unfortunately if you're just viewing uh
joining us although awesome thanks for
being here we are at record viewership
right now uh the the Bishops are are in
the driver's seat in this match they're
up three games seven and a half to four
and a half uh the last round was really
the round that put them there it was
much closer some big big turnaround
games last round uh now the the gnomes
are operating with their backs against
the wall they got to come up with some
victories to make a comeback here if not
we will be crowning our first ever
protest League champions and that will
be the Bishops
and that will mean that your predictions
will finally be correct Danny you know
what it's nice to get one out of 52
right I'm not gonna lie it feels good it
feels good but uh you know you take what
you can get when you're wrong all the
time all right so strange Stonewall
weird stuff Happening Here uh wow this
is
as Magnus created some winning chances
here I mean everybody if this Knight is
captured Magnus will take this night
with Shaq and then he's going to defend
the sea Pawn with this move Rook to C5
oh I love that where suddenly so has
some problems right I mean the
um
the miners are gone so you'd think with
a major presenting there should be
decent drawing chances but but this Pawn
is weak there's threats of Rook to C2
which honestly could be a nightmare if
the F2 Pawn comes Under Fire
um yes I think you must have forgot I
must have forgotten about this Knight E7
option because he went for this D5 push
himself yeah I think he I think he may
be miscalculated something about this
Knight coming to E7 because you have to
like
you have to like where this is headed
for Carlson suddenly he's finding a way
to win a pawn and the pawn that he's
going to win will that be enough to win
the major peace ending I don't know but
okay if Carlson wins is black
you you gotta think the gnomes are not
out of it right that's that's that's a
tall task to beat Wesley so with black
so if he does that he goes for exactly
the idea that we were just highlighting
Anna and I like magnus's chances here a
lot I like his chances too I think he's
going to beat Wesley so for maybe the
first time in a year a long time Wesley
so makes a habit of winning chess games
that guy you know go figure he wins a
lot of chess games but I think I think
Magnus Carlson may have been out for
blood here this move is really hard to
stop everybody and when that Rook gets
there yeah maybe b2's hanging but the
real problem is the F Pawn is under Fire
um okay so very good Rook to D2 stops it
but you still like Carlson's chances
there's he's got all the pressure here
six how cool is that move it's cool
Under Pressure what he wants to do I
think is to play
Maybe
maybe he tries to kick the queen and and
and get the king over here
um okay wait is Rook takes D5 and Asher
now that this Rook is
no because the queen E6 check okay but
the point everybody is this Rook is now
tied to the F Pawn because this Rook
left it so you know you may look for
tactics where this Rook on D2 becomes an
overloaded piece for all of its
responsibilities and what it has to
guard in the position
what's going on here I don't know but
I'm excited I'm really curious well with
a Magnus play here uh if he wants to
play for this The Rook text D5 move then
he should move the king away
um as weird as it seems can he just put
the King on h8 and
could be
but the problem is Rook D5 is still not
threatened I guess because really after
takes takes with check the the issue is
that the queen guards The Rook at the
end of that line so yeah
it's not just a win
yeah well um okay the the so Carlson
match is becoming all we hope for so at
least we're getting we're getting you
know it's nice when hype works out I
don't think this much hype has worked
out since LeBron James went into the NBA
so uh the the truth is this game here is
really proving to be something because
if Carlson can win his black then the
Gnomes have a Fighting Chance despite
being down three games heading into this
round
look at this move
he wants the pawn
he wants the pawn so he pushed H6 in
order to create some space for the King
on H7 if checked on King H7 no more
checks
yeah this is looking bad for Wesley if
this Pawn Falls and so does not manage
to get the C7 Pawn in exchange for
everybody black will go on to win this
ending for sure it's just way too much
of a majority uh for for white to
contend with so this is a critical
moment and it's one of those very very
very rare times where you see Wesley so
down on the clock to anybody right he's
down on time here and that that just
doesn't happen
but okay there's still let's let's let
Wesley think a little bit and and whoa
whoa what's going on here what happened
which which board is this mihiloff and
Rosenthal are are heating it up oh this
is very weird
what was that
the the the the the bishop is protected
so my first initial thought was uh oh
ouch town it's actually so white isn't
losing here but the last few moves we
missed started right here where black
went aggressively with E5 only to find
white was gonna return the favor and and
Sack a piece
who's better here and why I I ask you
because I have no idea but I'm I'm
liking mihilov's position
more than I did before he broke through
I mean I'll give you an example even if
I just take and let you get with check I
mean look at this position where I have
the bishop pair
I'm up upon
and could you say that my king is any
worse than yours I don't think so I I
don't think that Rosenthal may have and
he goes for exactly the line I just said
he takes on G3 I think he's gonna put
the King on E2 this Rook is going to get
in the action and I think Mia love has
chances here
wow I think he has chances here this is
this could be an epic comeback in the
making if we're looking at Carlson
coming up with a win if Rosenthal goes
down
okay the biggest issue right now I guess
if you're Norway is Grand Master Lee
seems to be up against it against a
Cobian he's he's down he's down half the
time
and he's worse in this benoni so Lee is
um
Lee is struggling and if and if a Cobian
gets this win that that really puts puts
uh St Louis behind the eight ball here
what's what's going on here is is it
Feingold and Nielsen anything but a
bunch of pieces getting traded I don't
know yet
yeah it looks like
um I'm still shocked how things changed
both on board one and on board four yeah
so those two games are looking great for
the Gnomes but I also play E5 here
uh which one Nielsen against against
Feingold if he plays E5
um this bishop is becoming a little
overloaded
crazy idea just throwing it out there it
probably doesn't work
if Knight takes here on C6 I wondered if
I could take it with the pawn on F6 I
guess it doesn't work because you have
Knight F5 in the end yeah I'm not
getting my head hopefully you're not
getting mated but I can take with the
Rook or the Knight and in some of these
positions I may be able to push your
Bishop back to H6 where it's just really
really passive after white gets F4
um
um this is a it could be and we thought
that this position was pretty equal
Android but Nielsen managed to and he's
going for it E5 I feel like they're
psychically picking up my vibrations
here I don't know I mean E5 feels I I
like White's chances this Knight on A4
is starting to feel a little empty like
he's regretting this little journey he
took on A4 because he's not very helpful
um now okay we've seen we've seen better
positions blown by Norway but this is a
position that really has the Grand
Master on the defensive Black is Black
is in trouble here I think he should
just take with the Knight one of the
main reasons everybody is after Bishop
G5 F4
um
okay if Bishop G5 F4 and the bishop
moves to H6 there's never a chance to
play Rook C8 because of 97 check maybe
he has Rook to C8 before moving the
bishop in that exact moment
um
could be actually no but then Queen to
C2 is a double attack because The
Bishop's Under Fire
ouch yeah
97 check winning The Rook
yeah this this is bad this is looking
very bad for Ben okay so we had to play
Bishop to d8 so he he's retreated his
pieces his Knight on A4 is not happy but
it's up to Nielsen to find the accurate
approach let's go back and see what's
going on between the two men of the hour
Grand Masters Wesley so and Magnus
Carlson yeah um yeah Mike has just told
me that Magnus is going to use his King
to protect the C7 pawn and that's it
that is happening classic Magnus right
using his King to defend the pawn LOL
right just kidding seriously E5 simple
chess
he's uh he's moving his King back to d8
he's going to guard C7
and the issue here everybody is that
so's Queen is sort of tied down right if
she ever moved and took there would have
been this rookie one check and then mate
so now so really has to find the ability
to keep everything guarded and it looks
like White's pieces are just getting
overloaded F2 has to be guarded D5
aha that's a resourceful move look at
that shot exactly I think I still with
Queen H1
yeah that's why Wesley so it's so great
that even if his position is inferior he
finds these kind of resources well I
think if you're Carlson now you're
evaluating whether you can trade queens
and then get the more active King in The
Rook ending and win but he decides no he
decides he needs to keep the ladies on
the board keeps pressure on D5
um
I think he may his King may find a new
home for safety on the queen side uh and
maybe even walk itself up to C5 I dare
say maybe
Maybe
oh that that would be that would be
incredible if the king decides the game
with King C5 and then the queen is just
stuck here look she can't go to F3
actually can't go to E4
is that really the worst idea in the
world okay no he didn't do it he played
rookie one
and then after Queen G2
maybe he should have gone from my idea
should have brought the King around I
like your idea maybe we got mated after
all but I like the idea oh Wesley so
blundered the first time Wesley saw
blunders in the history of the project
snake wins oh my gosh
that was it that was the that could be
the blunder heard around the world if
the Gnomes find a way to make a comeback
now in all fairness Wesley's Wesley was
really under the gun here this is a hard
position was playing extremely valid out
playing Wesley you can't continue to
find only moves one after the other
right and eventually he makes the
mistake desperate for a queen trade that
would free his King he blunders away the
queen everybody this is a deflection the
point is the King has to capture and the
game is over Wesley so resigns on the
spot
OMG as they say in social media
um
other boards okay so Carlson does his
job he beats the hottest player on the
planet yeah
what will happen in the other games
mihalov
milov got castled
wowzers now he has to guard the H Pawn
um E4 looks tasty because if if E4 Queen
takes you have Bishop to G5 checkaruski
oh right
and that wins the queen so so E4 is an
indirect defense of the H Pawn and it
opens the bishop I kind of like E4 if
I'm
if I'm mihilov here but Norway has a
chance it's not over the scoreboard
shows you like you see it everybody
right above our heads uh with that huge
Victory by Magnus Carlson they have put
themselves with three games still in
play they need two more victories at
least here
uh to fight back I think the game that's
really going to be tough for them is
this one here Jacobian seems to be
bringing down the hammer against Grand
Master Lee with yet another exchange
sacrifice
wow this is
this is really history
honestly this just looks over
yeah this just looks over that means it
may come down to mihalov having to beat
Rosenthal
but it doesn't matter anymore if akobion
wins
you're right and he has one it's over
it's over wait a second yeah with that
win eight and a half
they've won it's over the St Louis
Champions are the are the 2017 Pro chess
League
Champions the St Louis Bishops excuse me
whoa well that was a little
anti-climactic there because I wasn't
expecting the resignation there but that
was the
that was the honestly it was it was just
the unfortunate benoni I always say
don't play the baloney Jacobian shows
why this is tough and a Kobe improves
hero winning two great games in the
benoni now there's still some
interesting chess here and unfortunately
for the Gnomes it looks like
looks like mihila may be doing okay here
against Rosenthal but it's not going to
matter and Nielsen still has some
pressure against uh Feingold but also
doesn't matter because we officially
have Champions wow
oh this is uh
it was just
a sort of unexpected that the match is
already over with two games going on
Magnus Carson has just won he has beaten
the number two in the world Wesley so-so
the novage the Norwegians should be
happy for that of course but their team
is lost is losing and and I I knowing
knowing Magnus knowing Magnus and
knowing how competitive he is and how
bad he wants to win I don't think he's I
don't think he's happy with that I mean
I'm sure he's happy
I mean Magnus did his job today he went
4-0 he took out everybody including the
previously really Untouchable Wesley so
so you can't fault the the world
champion the strongest player on the
planet he showed up and did what he was
supposed to do unfortunately Norway was
not Fielding their strongest lineup
today and you know next year maybe
they'll come for revenge and have a
little bit more to say in the finals in
the protest league but we have to
congratulate uh St Louis because they
took it as seriously as they needed to
they fielded all their best players and
they were the more consistent team uh
and that's why they won today uh already
with eight and a half uh eight and a
half points they have secured the match
it is best of 16 everybody so eight and
a half is really all you need minimum
and uh and wow
wow wow wow
um
so uh the other two games of course we
should still check what's happening I
see that Captain Casanova AKA mihailov
has just declined the drill versus
Rosenthal
maybe he still doesn't know that they
lost already the match or he's simply
playing because his position is better
yeah I mean either way I think at this
point chess is still chess right we play
for the result we played a win as a team
but I think they might as well play it
out and I think from our perspective
we're going to be looking to get Wesley
so on the show now if we can
um because uh he you know despite going
down to the world champion in today's
match the truth is Wesley was was as
committed as any super GM has ever been
to their team along with Magnus Carlson
and he helped the bishops get the
victory overall in the season and we're
going to see if we can get one of the
one of the victors from the St Louis
Bishops on the show
um the uh the biggest game as to as to
why uh the the Bishops clinched it
really is this a Kobe and victory and
because we didn't get to look at it so
much let's back up a few moves and see
where the second the second brilliant
Jacobian exchange sacrifice occurred uh
the biggest this is actually an
instructive moment in the benoni in
general it's basic for so many more
advanced players but usually it's set in
the benoni if white can get E5
tactically and it and it works right and
it's not just a big simplification of
the pieces it's kind of like if black
can get D5 In the Sicilian sometimes you
have these Universal truths about a
given Pawn structure right so the
instructive thing is that usually in the
benoni if white is getting E5 and it's
not just a simplification it's a sign of
bad things to come for black and there's
a number of reasons for that one it
always creates this instantly strong
past d-pawn two when you have more space
in a position typically that means your
pieces had slightly better squares
because you had more options available
right we're just reading between The
Logical lines so if the position starts
to become tactical you're more powerful
pieces that had those better squares
because of your space usually that works
out for you so a Cobian knows that he
plays E5 and and we Anna you and I saw
this position we we predicted that this
was headed the wrong direction for Grand
Master Lee
and you know the position opens up
everything I just talked about as to why
a Cobian is just much better here and
it's just a good universal instructive
truth for all of you if white gets E5
and it works probably the benoni is
headed the wrong way
um really the fun thing though is right
here is is at first after he after he
stops Knight C4 Bishop G5 he sees the
opportunity for the exchange sack
sacrifices The Rook not because he even
intends on winning the exchange back but
because the dark squares are such a
problem and this D6 Pawn is such a
menace what would what would Simon
Williams say what would he call the
d-pawn Doug he has a name for every Pawn
one yeah
Derek Derek the d-pawn yeah Simon if
you're going to continue to give all
these pawns names maybe you could
publish it somewhere in like a Wikipedia
page or something that might help
everybody
is that Wesley so will be on air in
about 10 minutes
Wesley is joining us soon
the uh the world uh not the world
champion took down Wesley so and went
4-0 today but Magnus Carlson wanted more
than that uh I think he enjoyed this
team sport of Chess but more than he
ever thought he would uh we we've loved
having his competition and he's he's
been really active in his support of the
Gnomes and
um I think he wanted more he wanted to
win the whole thing but the best player
in the world will have to take that
energy and revenge in next year's season
I I uh I bet next year he doesn't wait
until week three or four to start
playing regularly for the Gnomes
certainly not I see him as the manager
of the team doing the lineups for every
week he's gonna he's gonna give Ari
antari and some of these other guys who
didn't schedule the finals a piece of
his mind because Magnus wants to exactly
exactly their excuse was the Swedish
League of course it's it's not an excuse
uh he they should have been here for the
protest league but it's true that both
hammer and orientare had to play today
in the Swedish league so that's why they
couldn't be here for the Norway gnomes
well it's unfortunate Magnus did his job
though we will have Wesley so who did
more than his job throughout this whole
year uh leading the leading the St Louis
archbishops
to the the protest League Championship
uh the first ever approaches League
champions that counts for history right
yep
the St Louis archbishops just became a
trivia question as my boy Mike Klein
would say uh who is the in 20 years from
now they'll quiz kids and say who won
the first ever approaches League
Championship and only us old people will
know the answer Anna we'll be old and
I'm already old oh my don't even mention
it can I see those wrinkles appearing
all over
yeah but there are still two games going
on so maybe we should talk about some of
those moves absolutely which one do we
want to look at I'm organizing making
sure I'm connected with Wesley here on
Skype sure
um it's an end game uh Bishop versus
Diet in mihaila versus Rosenthal
um
there there has been a few more draw
firsts now Rosenthal declined the draw
of course he's a pawn up
and in the other game
I don't know which one you have on the
screen I have Ben Ben I know I have
Nielsen's game against Ben and Nielsen
is doing his job as well he's uh he's
making up for for an advantage he blew
against Rosenthal last round he I mean I
don't know if he wins this game yet but
he's definitely out playing Ben Feingold
in the current setup
so yeah if it wasn't for the blunder in
the previous round then this would have
been a completely different story
it's so true right I mean if uh if me if
mihila takes care of Ben Feingold in the
previous round exactly we're looking at
a match where these games have us on the
edge of our seat as and uh but that's
what happens right it's uh one blunder
can turn everything around and it's
rapid chess for a reason because we we
like the fun
um and uh but St Louis did what they
needed to do Ben stayed on his toes
he got his opportunity to win that game
when when he was really under the gun
and and now he will looks like he's
going to lose this one but he will still
be a member of the the winning team as I
am attempting to connect with Wesley
here
yes and Ben said already yesterday that
he only wins a game when it's really
needed for the team so now this one
doesn't matter
so is Wesley joining us
uh just a fun stat but yes he is joining
us and I'm trying to bring him on Yo Kim
wins so it does make it a lot closer in
the final score of things it was nine to
seven and for those who actually watch
the whole thing and were with us the
whole time they know that this the this
match was not not quite the tiebreaker
crazy Affairs we had in the semi-finals
but very exciting down to the wire uh
really some blown blunders
um by by Norway is what they can blame
this match on the world champion did his
job we are waiting to be joined by
Wesley so uh Mike Klein just told me
that the St Louis uh Bishops can can at
the very least claim to have more titles
than the St Louis Blues hockey team uh
so and they've played 50 years so good
job for the St Louis archbishops I think
I think Rex singfield would like to know
that he should contact the owners there
at the blues and remind them that he has
one more ring than they do so uh no but
seriously congratulations to the
archbishops they are the 2 2017 Pro
chess League champions
um we will just let a big logo of the
Bishops be on the screen right now
because I can't think of anything else
more cool to do
um
but the games are over as you see Norway
wins the sorry St Louis wins the
championship by a score of nine to seven
a ton of fun and let's let's hear from
the man of the season is he the MVP
right who knows I think that he is the
MVP but Greg should let us know who is
going to win the most valuable player
prize
yeah I think I think that there's some
stats to calculate from what I believe
the MVP is a combination of something we
have officially stated based on like
minimum scores and stuff and I don't
know if there's a committee that decides
me on that if it's a tie or something
but
um I'm uh I I'm not involved I don't
know exactly the stats there but it
seems like with the season he had uh the
only thing that uh he could have done
better was not lose to Magnus Carlsen
here but you know what hey that happens
to the best of us even I've lost to
Magnus so you know hey come on right
um All Right Wesley
waiting for you buddy as soon as Wesley
gets here we will we will bring him on
the show let's pull up his game with
Magnus so that we're ready to go over it
and ask him joking
what
you will tell him to go through his last
game well I think we have to I think I
think we have to ask him about this
moment with E4 because I honestly feel
that perhaps it was slightly
yeah
that's wrong yeah and I'll get his
opinion maybe E4 was a little bit more
aggressive than he needed to be it felt
like after after the position started to
open up on the f-file was when was when
Magnus you know starting with this
position with 97 you know it felt like
black was in the driver's seat because
of all the weaknesses we were
highlighting here right
so maybe he agrees or maybe he doesn't
and and we will get his his opinion as
he is a much stronger player than than
us
um
so that'll be interesting the uh
we'll ask him whether he thinks he's the
MVP why not put these guys on the spot
and let them tell us whether they think
they're the best players you've seen
that you've played the best chess I
think you're the best player and ask him
ask him when he you know if he if he
thinks he could beat Magnus Carlson in a
match yeah no let's just ask certainly
that's a huge question nowadays all
right well he is he is with us and I'm
gonna go ahead and add him to our call
right now
um
hopefully for hoping for some video
here
um moving uh moving the video chat up
and hoping to have Wesley
join us via video which now he has
I think and Hey Wesley
Anna we've lost your video are you still
there
then oh it's muted
yeah
hello we've seen you have lost uh Anna's
video but Wesley can you hear me yes I
can hear you loud and clear Dan thank
you for joining us Wesley
congratulations
on leading the St Louis archbishops
to the 2017 Pro Chesley Championship how
much does this matter to you how how how
awesome is this for you to lead the team
to their first ever ever Pro chess
league title well it matters a lot now
we're we're a world champions you know I
have a I have a great team you know I
mean we're not the only players but I
like to congratulate my great teammates
varakobian Ben Feingold
and Nicolas rosental so this is a huge a
huge huge win for us
um most especially since we're
presenting the Saint Louis chess club
which is a really great place to be and
uh
starting last year I I have we built a
turning base here in St Louis so I so I
come here often to to work and practice
with other GMS so we're really proud to
to do it for them and also the first the
first pro chess League
we you know it's been very hard to to
get here all the way to the finals and
we needed a lot of things to
to to make it
through this far and
yeah and now we we finally did it so
next year we're gonna be ready to defend
our title it sounds like you have a lot
of uh a lot of affinity for the for the
city that you're playing from and
representing St Louis and just the
obviously the relationships you built
there with the club and with uh both Rex
and Jeannie singfield and how do you
feel it it is to just be able to bring
the the first ever Championship to the
city and and the fans there
well I'm very proud and happy I'm happy
hey yeah
sorry I was kicked out by Skype and I
missed the whole conversation
it's okay I was just asking Wesley how
he feels about the championship that
that they brought to uh St Louis and
we'll let him continue okay well I said
I'm very happy and proud and we're happy
to do it for the people for the players
here in St Louis and I mean not only me
I mean as I said we have a we have a
great team
um
and uh this year will be the 10th UF
Chef Championship that is held here in
St Louis and is going to start very soon
so uh
um this is a great start
and um and by the way this
this team that that played today is
basically the same team that won uh
three years ago in the USPS League
but this is this is bigger now we're
we're world champions and uh and other
than
my loss on the on the last game
uh this would be a very memorable for me
well before before we talk about that
game I think we wanted to give the fans
some insight into what you thought about
uh that game with Magnus but um speaking
on on the whole season you had uh Anna
Anna quoted stats in our pregame show
that you you came in with a 33 and a
half out of 37 points performance
amazing performance more committed than
any of the super GMS playing for their
teams and you know do you do you feel
you were the you were the MVP obviously
the MVP comes with a cash prize and and
uh whatever the first ever MVP but do
you feel like you uh you were the the
most committed super GM and deserving of
the MVP this year
well huh
[Laughter]
I'm not asking you to be cocky I'm just
asking you to be confident and say how
you feel you played this year
well uh it's uh it's hard to say it's
not not for me to decide
you know um winning the winning the MVP
is great but uh it's more important for
me to to win for for the team as a whole
and
um
first of all I'm not sure what the basis
of the MVP is
it's pretty much just whoever plays the
most awesome and you played pretty
awesome
[Laughter]
I think I think I think probably I mean
if you're curious about the stats
probably you and guys like York Meyer
had the best chances heading in you know
George was also very consistent played a
lot
um but uh if I had to if I had to give
you any spoilers I would say that you're
probably going to be the MVP so
congratulations uh thank you yeah
congratulations Wesley also Ben is here
in the chat saying that it's an easy MVP
for Wesley easy
MVP yeah Bennett Ben is your biggest fan
um which is good because
yeah he always everything's easy so uh
not easy as playing Magnus Carlson and I
know we don't want to we don't want to
talk about you know one of the only
losses you had all year but we might as
well it was a pivotal game in this match
and obviously we know Magnus won the
game but wasn't enough to help his team
can you give us any insight um now that
you know since we have roll number two
here where did you feel this game went
wrong for you
um we were analyzing perhaps uh the
approach taken starting on move 17 with
E4 and Then followed with D5 right after
was maybe a little bit unnecessarily
aggressive or do you feel like that was
fine and things went went awry later
yeah I feel he out he out played me
today I mean he played really well today
congratulations but
um I think first of all my 14th move
Knight E5
might be an accuracy okay perhaps I
should go D2 because then I wasted time
moving my knight back and forth
and then I felt that black was always
slightly better because
um of yes he has a better phone
structure okay
and you play
yeah oh sorry go ahead I was asking did
you play E4 because you were worried
that if you didn't change the structure
black might get E5 and kind of slowly
build up on on the king side
yeah that that's what that's why I felt
E5 is might come in Knight C6 but I
think Knight E4 is is a normal move
I just have to pray play precisely later
on and then on uh
that's it on move 27 I miss my last
chance to equalize
right and specifically which move do you
feel you should have played instead of
Rook E3
um
oh interesting okay so if you take on A4
you you end up trading the A4 Pawn for
the D5 pawn and you have pretty good
drawing chances there yeah and I only I
don't have much weaknesses
okay but so Rook ether can be like
considered like a mini blender
got it after which uh black is just much
better and even in the and I mean I
blundered my queen but it was already a
bad position right right very difficult
to defend that at that point okay well
um
played very well in the last game and
you know it's a team event so right well
your team was in a great position before
that anyway obviously you uh you had
gone 3-0 to help them get there and and
certainly one loss doesn't Define the
season but I know that you and Magnus
have a uh have a building rivalry I
don't think that you guys uh have played
since taught of Steel right no we
haven't and how do you how do you feel
you you match up against the world
champion these days you've obviously had
a phenomenal year I don't need to remind
you but you haven't lost a game over the
board in a really long time it's been
like months since so so how do you feel
you stack up against the world champion
these days
uh well I don't look that that far ahead
I just want to play uh one game at a
time right now I'm focused for the for
the US championship
and this is going to be a very crucial
event because it's the biggest uh
obviously the biggest National event in
in American chess
so I'm very focused on this and uh
um I just hope to to keep improving I
mean
um it's unfortunate I lost today but uh
I I think that's how chess players learn
is let's say if they study their losses
and uh learn concrete concretely from it
um
obviously as the game showed today I
still have a lot of areas
to able to improve upon
and uh when I when I play Magnuson North
in Norway hopefully I'll be
a better player by that
well uh if you continue to have uh this
this uh this approach and attitude I'm
sure you will be I mean you're about as
humble as any any chess player and and
certainly with the talent you bring to
the table Wesley the sky seems to be the
limit so we it's a pleasure talking to
you and and uh congratulations to your
team yeah and thank you Danny I think it
has been a pretty successful uh first
season for the protest league so far and
uh lots of people enjoy I mean the
server crashed earlier oh don't remind
me that's my head that's like me that's
like me reminding you of magnus's loss
as you remind me that the server crashed
so uh no but uh you're right it was it
wasn't a great start but uh it was it
was a finish that I think a lot of
people predicted I did pick your team to
go all the way FYI just so you know I
thought your team Wesley I also picked
St Louis so we are happy with our
predictions Danny and I predicted try to
predict the whole uh playoffs and we
were doing pretty badly but we managed
to get the winner and that's your team
it's very typical of a sports
commentator on ESPN to only remember the
times where they predicted something
correctly so I I was wrong most the time
but uh right about you what were you
gonna say buddy
yeah you upgrade inside both yeah I mean
great inside Daniel watch your video and
uh you almost got it uh everything
correct except for the Mars sale
migraines yeah well I didn't know that
Magnus was going to be so committed I
think he's upset I think he'll be back
for Revenge next year or look forward to
this a new stage for you guys to have a
rivalry on and I'm sure that he'll be
back for the Gnomes and you'll be back
for the Bishops uh I don't have any
other questions uh just just uh thank
you for for being the champion that you
are and and for joining us and uh look
forward to uh to following you and good
luck at the U.S Championship yeah good
luck there and also good luck at the
speed Chess Championship where you will
face Magnus once again
oh uh yeah well I have to go through
Anish first yeah he's got Geary first
he's for granted his match his match
against Anish Geary is May 25th
everybody for you big Wesley so fans out
there and uh just fans of the the next
big event that chess.com will roll out
May 25th is Anish Geary versus Wesley so
uh well since Anna brought it up let me
ask you how do you think you'll fare
there I mean obviously a totally
different format than the pro chess
League you instantly face off against
one of the other top players in the
world
um and it's and it's Blitz which is
which is tough right how do you think
you you'll you'll match up against a
niche in that match yeah it's a bit Finn
we also played chess 96 FIFA remember
well um
uh we'll see I'm very excited to to play
it I think the match will be exciting
especially since now Anish has been uh
winning more games than than before so I
think they might
be sorry that was funny
but but yeah I think it will be really
exciting of course it's uh it's gonna be
a very tough match honest here is a top
10 previously top five best chess player
in the in the world
um I just have to I have to play Fast
right I have to play Fast right
well we look forward to it it'll be one
of the really probably our first Marquee
matchup uh Nakamura takes on one of our
qualifiers May 3rd but uh that matchup
between you and Gary everyone can circle
on their calendars uh it'll be right
after I think you both returned from the
Moscow candidates event right and then
he's returning from from the Grand Prix
series but I'm not oh you're not playing
there right okay right okay well good
luck at the US Championship good luck in
the speed Chess Championship perhaps
Anna and I will be talking to you then
after another Victory and uh thank you
so much for joining us today Wesley
thank you congratulations once again to
you Wesleyan to the St Louis archbishops
I seen the chat that Ben is hoping to
join us now in the Stream
yeah Ben always wants to get on TV with
me he went away for a while but now he
wants to be back uh I think he's gone he
lost his last game intentionally to make
it close yeah exactly that's the kind of
thing Ben would say for sure
but yeah so uh good job St Louis our
Bishop and we're applying to defend our
title next year absolutely
congratulations to you the team the
whole city Wesley and uh good luck at
the U.S Championship we'll talk to you
soon okay bye thank you see you Wesley
bye
well there you have it the uh the top
the top player known as as Wesley so
um just awesome he's so humble yeah
I'm always amazed uh how humble he can
be
for being so good I would be like oh
just won the protest League yeah he's uh
he's amazing and uh he's super obviously
super strong to go with it
um
he's uh I'm trying to set up a little
bit of our
our setup here all right we kind of we
kind of lost your video because of the
yeah I have a huge head
that's okay
laughs
um I'm trying to uh trying to re-re set
up our system here that's when you're
not set up for multiple calls and then
you go to multiple calls you know what
this is why I'm a one-man band I should
be you know a one-man band I'm playing a
million different instruments here at
once but there you go so now we have
Anna Rudolph
I don't know where I am in my big head
are doing great
it's been great
and I think if Ben wants to join us sure
why not we're here right
yeah yeah let's call Ben
um absolutely if Ben wants to join us
let's bring him on
um Ben are you on Skype
I assume you are somewhere here
the uh
the legendary Ben Feingold we've got a
few minutes here before we lose all the
fans but uh everybody wants yeah saying
in the chest Skype me and also you guys
in the chat prepare your questions to
Ben I'm sure you have many I just I just
resent a contact request to men that
hopefully he accepts and then we can
have a conversation with Ben on the show
yeah give us any questions you want for
Ben
um you try to keep them PG at least
PG-13 and uh
and we'll see how Ben feels obviously
he's as excited as anybody Ben loves the
protest League loves playing online for
the St Louis team so uh I don't I don't
buy that he lost that last game on
purpose but we'll give him a pass uh and
uh Ben I've sent you uh we we we're
we're connected on Skype I think you
just gotta
if not we'll just we'll pretend you're
here in spirit I could have a
conversation with you and try to
anticipate your answers so
um
uh anyway Anna great stuff it was
awesome to have Wesley on the show
really it's just incredible that was
that was so close and I think Norway had
their chances in that middle round uh
but St Louis proved to be the favorite
in the end because of their consistency
yeah yeah and they have played the same
team basically every week so that shows
that they've really determined and I
think that's what makes a champion so of
course the Norwegians are a great team
great players but they couldn't bring
always the same lineup
um while the Saint Louis Arts Bishops
they have always brought their best
players Benny's saying that he hasn't
received any contact requests
I'm trying to call him then
hmm
hey Anna
trying to get bent on but I think we
might just have to call it call it a day
here if uh if we can't quite oh he's not
here you
let me uh yep you're back oh cool
oh that's a pretty eye I really wanted
to have been on the show he's saying
call me dude I'm trying to call him but
uh you gotta tell him to add me Ben add
me
add Danny
all right well
don't think it's going to quite work out
in the meantime let me announce if I
have read correctly then Greg has told
me that I finished 36 in the prediction
game I don't know how
36 out of 2 600
geez that's actually pretty awesome I'm
sure that's better than I did uh I I
think so I'm sorry about that Danny no
you don't have to tell me don't tell me
how I did I know
um well methods are still way cooler
than my methods my methods I think
worked out in the end you know uh maybe
maybe some didn't quite deliver the
results I wanted but uh
in all seriousness I think we're going
to bring the show to a close band I
don't know that we're going to be able
to get out the technical stuff here uh
we appreciate everybody for being here
honestly this has been one of the most
thrilling and fun experiences
we've ever had on chess.com and I think
for the for the global Chess World this
hopefully is a sign of things to come
um I think next year it'll be even more
fun even more entertaining and probably
even more of the world's top Grand
Masters competing if that's even
possible we had worlds numbers one two
three four five six seven I mean we had
all pretty much all of them but maybe
playing even more
um and uh congratulations once again to
the St Louis archbishops congratulations
to the Gnomes on a phenomenal season
simply phenomenal season right there in
the end and uh
congratulations and thank you to the
fans for supporting this and and we look
forward to seeing you next year
yeah and thanks to Greg shahadi thanks
to the whole team of chess.com thanks to
you Danny for bringing us all together
to bring all these uh streams the
commentary shows uh the whole
Championship weekend was epic
yesterday's tie breaks and eight hours
of Chess
um 11 weeks of protest league and then
the championship weekend this has been
three months so far and I don't know
what I'm gonna do next week without
protest League
well we have the qualifiers starting and
so we'll remind everybody that's what
you're doing next week uh not exactly a
week but uh you know we got a lot to
look forward to with this features
Championship who will qualify who will
be this this on this person with no face
to play one of the top four Blitz and
Rapid players in the world uh make sure
you tune in check the calendar that's
going to be our real Focus for probably
the remainder of the year and we get we
get all these big players back again
with some of these huge huge matches
totally different format than what we've
seen here but just epic throwdowns
between studs and in these fast time
controls so
um
Anna thank you for being here thanks for
thanks for flying alongside thanks for
having me and uh and we'll we wish
everybody the best and we'll we'll talk
to you later